Wir haben eigentlich so ein Focusrite Red Display Interface.
Habe ich eigentlich.
Und zwei so Headsets.
Die kann ich dir zeigen, aber die sind halt irgendwie,
kennst du das, dieses Leder von diesen Schalen?
Ja, das ist bei meinen auch so.
Das finde ich total komisch.
Also die sind jetzt auch nicht alt.
Na gut, die sind auch schon vielleicht fünf Jahre alt, die Headsets.
Aber für so einen plus 200 Euro Kopfhörer würde man eigentlich erwarten,
dass das ein bisschen länger hält.
Wir haben jetzt am Anfang unserer Podcast-Karriere,
bevor wir reich und berühmt waren,
noch nicht so tief in die Tasche gegriffen.
Die guten 250 Euro.
Bei meinen Kopfhörern ist das so,
ich habe hier diese Bose 500
und die habe ich auch nicht für 200
noch was Euro neu gekauft,
sondern irgendwie bei Kleinanzeigen.
Aber neu wären die halt so gewesen
und die waren mehr oder weniger neu,
als ich die geholt habe.
Keine Ahnung, was da los war.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich die jetzt auch schon eine Weile
benutzt und
es bröckelt aber jetzt auch ab und
ich habe die sogar zweimal,
weil ich die einmal im Büro und einmal zu Hause hatte
und bei denen zu Hause, die sind
schwarz und da sieht man es und bei denen im Büro,
das ist so hellgrau, da sieht man es eben nicht so gut.
Irgendwann merkt man,
wir haben die letzten Male nicht dran gedacht und das dann
irgendwie immer abgemacht und ich habe dann schon angefangen.
Zäh war
zwischen uns
und uns.
Irgendwie ein paar dünne Socken drüber stülpen.
Ja, so ein Buff über den Kopf gezogen,
so ein Halstuch drüber gezogen.
So ein Popfilter.
Filter.
Hast du das schon aufgenommen?
Macht das ein besonderes Geräusch, wenn die hier so ficken?
Das ist der Ase.
Das Ase mehr Mode.
Als die Aufnahme läuft,
ihr könnt euch das dann nachher anhören, wie das klingt.
Aber ich bin auch mehr infizient.
Wir sind gerade im Cardioid-Mode.
Und ich belese mich gerade zu den Modi.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher.
Ich habe aber jetzt nicht gemerkt, dass das einen Unterschied gemacht hat, dass das schlechter klang.
Na, willst du noch mal vorher hören, ob ich jetzt in der Mitte bin oder irgendwo sonst wo?
Das klang nicht schlecht, das ist offensichtlich getrennt.
Pass auf, piep.
Wir machen jetzt mal den Test und sagen mal der Reihe nach einen Satz.
Hallo, ich bin hier, um den einen Satz zu sagen.
Lorem Ipsum, Dolorzit Amit.
Perfekt, so, das war jetzt im Nieren-Modus.
Jetzt machen wir den ganzen Tanz nochmal im Stereo-Modus.
So, wir sind jetzt alle hier, wir haben uns zusammengefunden, um einen Satz zu sagen.
Hallo, ich bin hier, um einen Satz zu sagen.
Äh, ich wollte es rückwärts sagen.
Amit sind dolor, ipsum lorem.
Aber ich konnte es nicht im Kopf.
Ich bekomme den Nerdpreis, das war jetzt schon wieder.
Man gehört halt, wie erst du umgeschaltet hast, dass dir erstmal nichts ändert.
dann dauert es drei Sekunden, dann gab es einen Klack
und dann haben die Signale.
Also ich dachte, dass das wirklich
analog quasi umschaltet.
Nicht, dass der Zink irgendwie einen Chip hat, der umschaltet.
Also wenn du es
auf die Nierencharakteristik
stellst, ist es schon darauf optimiert,
dass das Signal wirklich auch von vorne
kommt. Das machst du,
wenn du von vorne reinsprechen möchtest.
Aber es gibt ja keinen Modus für...
Es gibt einen Rundrum-Modus.
Aber es gibt keinen Modus für nur vorne,
wenn ich vor dem Mikro sitze.
Das ist die Nieren-Charakteristik.
Ich dachte immer, das wäre dann besser für den Aura.
Da habe ich letztens voll das Eigentor geschossen.
Ich meine, man wird das jetzt nicht großartig raushören.
Es klang ja wirklich so, also im Nieren-Modus,
deine Stimme klang perfekt und bei uns war es dann wirklich so mehr Hintergrund.
Und bei Serio war es überhaupt nicht der Fall.
Da klang gar nicht gleich, wo wir halt geteilt auf die Seiten sind und du halt gestellig klangst.
Hattest du schon ins WLAN reingeschafft?
Ja, ja.
Okay, ich werde
diese Sequenz einfach mal am Anfang von
Podcast tun und dann können wir unser audiophiles
Publikum einfach mal zeigen.
Wie die davon haben, nachher werde ich
aufgeklärt.
Ich hatte so einen Typen da für so eine Fensterinspektion,
also eine Hausverwaltung, der ist aber vorbeigekommen,
hat sich die Fenster angeschaut und wir haben eine Weile
geplaudert, war auch super netter, lieber ein Dude.
Und mein 3D-Drucker
lief gerade und der fand das so
faszinierend, was man damit machen kann,
dass es ja voll die coole Technik ist und dass man
da alles Mögliche drucken kann.
Ich habe schon fast gewollt, die wouldn't download a car reference
zu machen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob die ja die verstanden hätte.
Inwieweit habe ich dann noch eine Weile
weitergequatscht über alles Mögliche und irgendwann erzählt er mir,
dass es ja schon so manche Sachen gibt,
die gibt es einfach nicht,
aber die bräuchte man.
Und er hat zum Beispiel so einen Akkuschrauber
von Matebo, heißt die Firma,
glaube ich? Metabo. Metabo, genau,
danke.
Und für die gibt es halt keine Wandhalterung, wo er
den Akku rausnehmen kann und das Ding an die Wand hängt.
Aber von allen anderen gibt es die, aber von denen nicht.
Dann sind sie selber schon aus Holz gebaut, schon dreimal kaputt gegangen,
weil sie so friemlich klein sind.
Und dann meine ich, während er es sagt, gehe ich so auf meinen Laptop,
schaue so kurz auf Thingiverse, wenn nicht auf Thingiverse, auf Printables.
Habe direkt hier so, meinst du sowas?
Ja schon, genau das da.
Das ist sogar mein Ding, was da drin hängt.
Ein Beispielfoto.
Dann habe ich vorhin gesagt, du tue ich dir halt das Ding.
Und morgen kommt er eh nochmal für die letzten paar Wohnungen über mir.
Blicke ich bei Julius hin.
Kann er sich da mal Julius abholen?
Nicht schlecht.
Hat sich mega gefreut.
Ist doch schon ein geiles Spielzeug.
Na klar. Ich habe mir auch schon mal Ersatzteile
für eine Spülmaschine drucken lassen
vom Kumpel, weil irgendwie so die Räder
waren irgendwie so zerbröckelt und das ist
immer rausgefallen und war ein altes Ding
und dann gibt es natürlich
keine Ersatzteile, aber
dann muss man da halt irgendwie das ein bisschen ausmessen
und dann hat der Kumpel da irgendwie
das halt mir gedruckt und dann ging das.
Das ist halt das Geile, so Ersatzteile, so Kleinigkeiten,
vor allem so Teile, die es nicht mehr gibt,
weil die Hersteller entweder gar nicht mehr existieren
Bock mehr auf das Modell haben. Dafür ist
halt echt richtig nice. Ja, oder wenn
so Sachen nicht zu Ende gedacht wurden.
Ich habe jetzt auch so einen
Campingstuhl, den man so zusammenstecken kann.
Und der hat halt so kleine Füßchen.
Die waren aus Gummi. Und die sind aber
irgendwie relativ schnell auch kaputt gegangen und dann
durchgestochen und waren halt nicht mehr zu gebrauchen.
Und außerdem war es so, wenn man sich auf irgendwie
eine Wiese setzt, dann ist man relativ schnell
eingesunken mit den beiden.
Weil so spitze Füße waren. Genau.
Du brauchst so Schneeschuhfüße.
Also das ist jetzt noch bei mir
noch ein Projekt, was noch gemacht werden muss, aber eine Freundin
hatte das irgendwie bei ihrem Vater schon mal gemacht und
hat jetzt so richtig schöne Gummifüße, die haben eine bisschen
größere Aufstellfläche und da setzt du nicht mehr ein mit.
Also richtig kleine Teller da drunter,
wo du einfach gut sitzen kannst.
Richtig gut.
Ja, das ist echt wahr, so
Dinge modden. Ich finde es auch geil, das ist einfach für
Ja, oder halt wirklich Ersatzteile machen für
was, was halt sonst irgendwie kaputt wäre und
nicht irgendwie was Neues kaufen müssen, das
finde ich schon ganz gut.
Da wir ja jetzt voll schon
live eingestiegen sind in die Themen, dann
eins aus der Mitte, weil das passt gerade zu gut.
Moment.
Wollt ihr euch nicht erstmal begrüßen?
Sind wir noch in der Pre-Show oder fangen wir jetzt schon wirklich an?
Wir sind vor der Show.
Hi, Hendrik.
Hey, Kilian.
Warte mal, wie stellen wir dich jetzt eigentlich vor?
Ihr könnt Marc sagen, ihr könnt Magnesium sagen.
Hallo Marc.
Hey Marc.
Magnesium.
Ja, so entstand das ja sogar.
Ach so?
Ja, ja.
Moment, also, hallo Zuhörer, willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge 58, wir haben heute den Magnesium zu Besuch, ihr kennt ihn unter anderem aus dem Akronomisierbar-Chatraum.
Ja, der unglaublich große, aktive Matrixraum mit den tausenden von Leuten.
Wir mussten einfach die Liste der Leute, die in diesem Channel sind und noch nicht zu Gast in diesem Podcast waren, um einen niedriger machen, um das der Null anzunehmen.
Das werden wir schaffen.
Ich fühle mich geehrt, dass heute der Tag ist.
Da habe ich auch schon eine ganze Woche.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich kann es auch ein bisschen daran gescheitern,
dass wir irgendwann eine lange Pause gemacht haben.
Das könnte sein.
Wir sind ein bisschen unzuverlässig geworden
in der Frequenz dieser,
wir haben die Frequenz dieses Podcasts
ein bisschen runtergefahren.
Wir haben eine sehr spezifische Schedule.
Die ist halt nur chaotisch und nicht weiter definierbar.
Aber die Folgen können, wenn sie kommen.
Irgendwann wird bestimmt jemand da
eine Regel daraus erfinden.
Es ist einfach ein Free-Body-Problem.
Hat einer von euch diese Sendung?
Die Serie war gut.
Die Serie war richtig gut.
Ich bin erst bei Folge 4, also er erzählt nichts.
Es gibt einfach eine Challenge an alle Zuhörer.
Es gibt eine Gesetzmäßigkeit,
die die Frequenz von akronomisierbar Folgen beschreibt.
Das geht doch wohl im Plan.
Und wir versuchen das irgendwann so.
Und wenn die jemand voraussagen kann,
dann ist er in der nächsten Folge eingeladen.
Das ist eine sehr viel größere Höhle,
als es das Jahr war.
Und wenn sie jemand
vorhersagt, dann müssen wir einfach
die nächste Folge anders planen und dann hast du
einfach falsch vorhergesagt. Ne, die Person, die
das vorhersagt, hat ja dann in der Hand, wann die nächste
Folge stattfindet.
Stimmt.
Ich glaube, wir haben uns da einer Vulnerability
geöffnet.
Was haben wir denn heute so für Themen in diesem
Channel? Ich will mein 3D-Druck-Thema
ganz kurz abrunden, weil ich fand das
super witzig.
und ich habe eigentlich was mitbringen wollen,
habe aber nicht das Richtige mitgebracht, sondern das Falsche.
Und zwar habe ich, falls ihr mir auf Mastodon-Folk habt,
ihr habt es wahrscheinlich eh schon gesehen,
mich vor einer Weile mal in den MRT gelegt,
nur aus dem Grund heraus, dass ich meinen Hirn schon länger drucken möchte.
Und ich wusste halt nie, wie man an die Daten kommt.
Man kann ja nicht einfach zur Radiologie gehen und sagen,
Haben sie mal irgendwie ein bisschen Downtime oder was kostet das?
Weil das ist teuer.
Darf ich mich da mal kurz reinlegen?
Deswegen habe ich lange drüber nachgedacht und irgendwann zufällig in einem Café einen
Aushang entdeckt über eine medizinische Studie.
Wait a second, kriege ich meine Daten?
Na klar, geil, bin dabei.
War sehr witzig, das war ja vor ein paar Wochen.
Das war auch eine lustige Studie.
Ich habe eine halbe Stunde in der MIT gelegt und hatte zwei Köpfe in der Hand und durfte
dann so Wissensfragen beantworten,
da mussten sie essentiell Dinge einprägen
und die Fragen richtig beantworten.
Ich habe danach nochmal nachgefragt.
Ich hoffe,
ich meine, das macht es ja nicht kaputt, wenn
der Quatsch hat, ey, mal zuhört. Bullshit.
Die Idee war, dass man
quasi in so einen Automatismus reinkommt
und irgendwann nicht mehr wirklich nachdenkt über die
Fragen. Deswegen muss es auch eine ganze Weile dauern,
also anderthalb Stunden lang diese sehr eintötigen Fragen
beantworten. Aber du musst es halt schon
dir acht
merken und die halt immer richtig wiedergeben,
hast immer nur zwei Sekunden Zeit, um zu antworten.
Ich habe es versucht, alle zu reden,
aber ich habe mal eine Frage kurz eingeschlafen.
Das war das Hauptproblem,
mit dem ich kämpfen musste. Ich hatte die Augen
offen und irgendwann Augen auf.
Fuck, das Zeichen ist schon weg.
Ich fand es auch das, woran ich
scheitern würde. Du sitzt, liegst halt so da.
Das ist so ein bisschen sensory deprivation.
Ja, genau. Dein Kopf ist eingeklemmt.
Du hast so ein neues Gäste in den Kopf
hören, damit du den nicht so richtig laut hörst.
Das Hintergrund dieses Wummern. Aber trotzdem
könnte ich mir als unwahrscheinlich einschläfern
vorstellen. Ja, das kommt drauf an. Also ich war
schon zweimal im MRT. Beim ersten Mal
bin ich alle Hüllentode gestorben und
dachte, wann komme ich hier jemals wieder raus? Weil das
so eng war und so laut und ich nicht wusste,
wie lange ich da jetzt eigentlich drin sein werde und so weiter.
Und dann war das
eine
Stunde oder so.
Und dann hatte das
auf jeden Fall auch nicht geklappt, was da irgendwie
gemacht werden sollte. Also musste ich kurz danach
nochmal zum MRT, also als ich den
nächsten Termin bekommen habe dann.
Es tut mir leid, wir haben hier immer leider nichts gefunden.
Naja, und da wusste ich dann noch,
was ich mich einlasse und dann habe ich mich da auch reingelegt
und dann bin ich auch fast eingeschlafen.
Das war sehr unterschiedlich.
Maximal.
Ich muss bloß daran denken,
dass ich halt so in Bussen, Zügen und Flugzeugen
und auf Beifahrersitzen ausgezeichnet,
manchmal auch auf dem Fahrersitzen,
sehr gut schlafen kann.
Oh Gott.
Weil einfach dieses
leichte, dieses
tiefe Rauschen, dieses braune Rauschen
und dieses leichte Vibrieren.
Aber es ist definitiv kein einheitliches Rauschen, was du da hast.
Also du hast schon ein sehr lautes Wummern.
Ja.
So ein ganz schräger Techno.
Aber es ist schon rhythmisch, oder?
Es ist schon rhythmisch.
Klar, die einzelnen Bildgebungsverfahren,
sag ich mal, die haben schon ein erkennbares Pattern.
Aber du merkst, wann wieder derselbe Scan anfängt.
Aber rhythmisch impliziert da,
dass es irgendwie sehr gleichmäßig ist.
Aber das ist eigentlich nicht krass.
Jedenfalls habe ich dann nochmal nachgefragt
und sie haben mir auch sehr schnell danach, also ich glaube,
es war eine Woche später, die Daten schon geschickt
und dann habe ich mich kurz softwaremäßig auseinandergesetzt,
bin über ein lustiges Tool namens
Swiss Skull Stripper gestolpert,
weil du kriegst ja deinen gesamten Schädel
und du willst ja nur das Hirn raus extrahieren
aus den volumätrigen Bildern.
Zufällig auch der Spitzname eines Berner
Massenwörders.
Der Swiss Skull Stripper.
Aber hat erstaunlich
funktioniert, vor allem, weil du dann so lustige Features
zur Optimierung der Daten hast, wie
der Smooth-Button.
Klick dem nicht so häufig,
sonst hast du ein richtiges Smooth-Brain.
Aber
am Ende habe ich dann
mein Hirn gedruckt.
Ich habe es auch dabei, in 50% Größe.
Du hast es vergessen.
Ich hatte das mit auf Arbeit.
Mein Chef hat mir gedacht, das ist größer als gedacht.
Also man muss sagen, es ist so groß wie ein Tennisball.
Das ist die 50% Größe.
Ich habe es einmal noch in 100% mittlerweile gedruckt.
In hirnfarbenem Filament auch,
weil ich es rausgesucht habe.
Was ist denn hier passiert?
Die glatte Stelle da hinten, das ist JavaScript.
Hast du doch ein Smooth Brain.
Als ich das gesehen habe in den Daten,
war es ein weirder Gedanke.
Ich muss mal ganz kurz dazu sagen,
wenn man sich das Gehirn von Kian von vorn anguckt,
ist das ein ziemlich schönes,
generisches Gehirn.
Aber hinten rechts wird es irgendwie so ein bisschen...
Ja, das sind MRT-Artefakte.
Also von dem, was ich online gefunden habe,
oder lag das daran, dass du hinten den Kopf auflagst?
Ich hoffe nicht, dass das
dein Hirn deformiert wird.
Du hast einen ziemlich weichen Schädel,
dass das geht.
Aber ich fand es auf jeden Fall super witzig.
Und habe das denen auch nochmal geschickt
und die waren auch so begeistert.
Oh, das ging ja wirklich sogar richtig gut.
Da haben wir nochmal gefragt, welche Software brauchen wir dafür?
Und was für ein Drucker?
Ich habe nochmal angefunden, wenn ihr Bock habt,
ich drücke euch auch eure Hörer.
Also drücken wir uns eine ganze Weile.
Die Struktur, ich habe es dann so Lobotomie-Style
in der Mitte geteilt und die Hälften
ein-in-in-Zinn gedruckt.
Sind da auch welche überhängenden Strukturen
dabei? Es sieht sich in Grenzen
nur in der Kante selber, deswegen ist da ein bisschen
unsauer, das sieht bei dem großen ein bisschen besser aus.
Aber es ist erstaunlich
gut geklappt. Ist ganz schön schwer auch.
100% Info.
Nee.
Nicht schlecht. Ich muss es noch
aus so TPU drucken, damit es squishy ist.
Ich habe ja schon gesagt,
Das ist Pilar einfach.
Du nimmst das jetzt einfach als
du machst davon jetzt Silikonabdrücke
und dann können wir Jelly-Gehirn-Briggs
quasi. Das wäre auch sehr witzig.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall
die STL davon auf Printables hochgeladen.
Also wenn ihr
auf Printables geht, nach Gehirnsuch,
das ist Kilians Gehirn.
Ihr könnt das jetzt selber zu Hause nachdenken
durch euren eigenen Kilian drucken.
Ich habe kurz darüber nachgedacht, dann dachte ich mir, das ist eine
STL von einem Hirnscan mit Artefakten.
Das ist absolut nicht Privacy-Problem,
wenn ich das so hatte.
Hoffentlich. Für die Zukunft auch.
Irgendwann wird trotzdem jemand dein Gehirn
komplett reverse-ingenieren.
Ich werde schon so ein bisschen paranoid,
dass mir dann irgendjemand schreibt, du, also übrigens,
die Stelle würde ich mir doch nochmal angucken lassen.
Aber dann würde ich diese Info bekommen.
Und das kriege ich nicht, wenn es closed source bleibt.
Das stimmt, das stimmt.
Also ich meine, besser so als gar nicht wissen.
Ist auf jeden Fall witzig, wenn man dann,
auch bei dem Kleidemach ist es nicht relevant,
aber im Großen, glaube ich,
ein paar Ecken mit Sandpapier nochmal nachbearbeitet
und ihr dann über den Hendrik Helds gerade neben den Tannenzapfen.
Es hat gewisse Ähnlichkeiten.
Also ich sage mal so, du hast es ja aus weißem Material gedruckt.
Wenn du da jetzt noch ein paar grüne Blätter drum rummachst,
dann ist es ein Blumenkoll.
Stimmt eigentlich.
Ja.
Ja, war auf jeden Fall eine witzige
Also drückt euch eure eigenen Kehrer ein Gehirn,
so lange ist er noch geändert.
Ihr könnt auch eure eigenen Gehirne drucken.
Ich glaube, ich werde das nochmal in einem Blogpost zusammenfassen,
wie man das gemacht hat, aber das war echt trivial.
Das war eine witzige Experience.
Ich glaube, das Schwerste daran ist,
einen MRT-Termin zu bekommen.
Ja, das ist sehr gut,
wenn man einfach so eine Random-Studie findet.
Obwohl ich jetzt letztens
für meinen Knie dann einen Quaradunfall
zum MRT musste
und da habe ich einfach das großartige Glück gehabt,
dass es halt ein Berufswegunfall war.
Und da habe ich beim MRT angerufen,
nachdem ich der, wie heißt das,
der Durchgangsarzt gesagt hätte,
ich brauche einen MRT-Termin.
So, fuck.
Das waren ja bestimmt Monate,
ruft da an.
Und die so, ja,
wie schaut es am neun Nachmittag aus?
Klar.
Okay.
Kein Problem.
Und dann beim zweiten Termin,
jetzt nochmal zum Abschluss,
haben sie mich gefragt,
ja, passt bei Ihnen in der Früh?
Ich so denkend,
ja, 8 Uhr, klar, kein Problem.
Die so, gut.
Ich habe sie jetzt für 6.40 Uhr eingeschrieben.
Excuse me.
da ist noch dunkle
da kannst du ja was durchmachen
einfach so
dann schläfst du auf jeden Fall
aber dein Knie gedruckt hast du dir noch nicht
ne, da klappt der Swiss Scouse Jouper nicht so
außerdem habe ich die Daten nur auf CD
und das ist so
die liegen auf meinem Schreibtisch, aber
eine CD lesen, wie
ich habe hier noch so ein CD-Laufwerk
USB-CD-Laufwerk
könnten die da noch mal schnell einlesen
ich glaube ich habe auch irgendwo so ein Ding
finden. Optische Daten
die anderen Daten habe ich per E-Mail bekommen.
Eieieiei.
Unverschlüsselt. Natürlich.
Aber von der TU-Mail-Adresse an meine
bei Fast-Mail-Ghosted-Adresse.
Das heißt, es hat zumindest keinen Google-Server.
Er hat gerade davon geredet, dass er die Daten,
die Scandaten...
Die Scandaten habe ich nirgendwo hochgeladen.
Die Scandaten habe ich per E-Mail bekommen, aber die Scandaten habe ich nicht veröffentlicht.
Ich habe die daraus extrahierten
3D-Modelldaten hochgeladen.
Achso, das ist quasi bloß das
Surface Shape quasi. Von dem
Gehirn selber. Aber nicht, also
mein MRT-Scan ist nicht öffentlich. Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich damit ein Problem hätte, aber das wäre definitiv
mehr, da müsste ich nochmal mehr drüber nachdenken.
Würde dir der
Swiss Skull Stripper auch helfen,
den äußeren, also das Negativ
davon zu drucken?
Das will man nicht.
Also ich habe einmal die 3D-Daten.
Du könntest den Rest von deinem Schiedeldruck ein bisschen anmalen.
Also ich
möchte es gar nicht zeigen, wie schlimm das aussah.
Aber man könnte sich einen Killian
zum Basteln mit Gehirn rauslegen.
Ich fände es sehr geil, alles zu drucken.
So irgendwie noch ein Skelett komplett.
Das wäre der Hammer.
Ja, mal so ein Ersatzknie.
Oh, geil.
Also das wäre schon stark, wenn du es selber druckst.
Da kriegst du auch mehr schneller Termine.
Ich bringe alles mit, ihr müsst es nur machen.
Du kannst es direkt mit Halterung für die Bohrmaschine kombinieren.
Oha.
Aber wäre das nicht super klug?
einfach solange man noch irgendwie in seinen 20ern, 30ern ist,
alles Knochen mal so abscannen und Sicherheitskopien für später zu machen.
Da kannst du einfach nur Hüfte drucken, wenn du Bock hast.
Und zwar das Original von damals.
Heißt das denn eigentlich auch noch Exoskelett,
wenn man das noch ein bisschen verlängert?
Oder Exo heißt doch außen, oder?
Exoskelett wäre prinzipiell außen.
Aber ich meine, wenn du Scandaten hast, kannst du ja perfekt andocken.
Genau, du kannst ja dann auch das Ganze noch mit nach innen lagern,
wenn du sowieso alles aufmachen musst.
Das ist schon cool.
Jetzt wird es krass.
Dann wären die Olympischen Spiele auf jeden Fall völlig absurd.
Okay.
Ich drehe mal zu diesem Zeitpunkt
die Sensitivität ein bisschen runter,
weil wir ein Ticken übersteuern.
Was ist jetzt passiert?
Ist natürlich gut mit der Aufnahme
im Augenblick, dass es passt.
Aber besser als die Rest auch noch übersteuert.
Ihr macht das ja noch nicht so lange.
Der Witz ist immer, den passenden Übergang zu dort
zu finden, wo man weiterredet.
Also manchmal, wenn ich...
geschnitten jetzt. Ich bin doch nicht geschnitten.
Ich bin neulich dann auch mal aufs Knie
gefallen, aber irgendwie
gescannen lassen musste ich es mir
glücklicherweise nicht. Es geht noch, aber es tut auch
nach einer Woche immer noch so ein bisschen weh.
Bisschen.
Ja, also ich bin auch eher tendenziell
der Mensch so, wird ja schon von
alleine besser. Aber also
nach dem Fahrradunfall war das halt,
ich konnte nicht laufen.
Ja, das ist natürlich krasser.
Die Bänder nicht durchgerissen, aber zwei Bänder
angerissen. Das hat man auch gut gemerkt.
Mir ist das Dumme passiert.
Ich mache beim Fahrradfahren
ein Selfie machen.
Dieser Start allein schon.
Naja, es war eine längere Fahrradtour.
Es war eine hübsche Gegend und ich wollte es
immer so ein bisschen dokumentieren, weil ich
da zwischendurch zeigen möchte, wie es mir zu dem Zeitpunkt
ging, als ich da irgendwie den Berg hochfahre.
Aber so wirklich live, wie es dir ging.
Also deswegen nicht anhalten.
Ich fand es schade, dass ich... Also was passiert ist,
ist, ich habe das Selfie gemacht und in dem Moment
rutscht mir das Telefon aus der Hand,
landet auf dem Asphalt
auf dem Display. Glücklicherweise bin ich bloß mit
10 kmh Geschwindigkeit gefallen, weil es halt bergauf
ging und ich so, oh Gott, mein Telefon
ist aufs Display gefallen, mach eine Vollbremsung,
aber ich hatte halt Klickpedale drin und das war
das allererste Mal, dass ich nicht rechtzeitig
mit dem Fuß aus der Pedale rausgekommen bin.
Jetzt bin ich so ein bisschen auf die Seite
gefallen und der permanente Schaden,
den ich habe, sind jetzt Pixelfehler hier auf meinem
Display. Das bewegt
sich nicht mit.
ein bisschen traurig.
Hendrik hat mir diesen
Pixelfehler schon vor ein paar Tagen gezeigt
und da hat er so ein schönes
Starry Night Wallpaper gehabt.
Und da fallen die Pixelfehler erstaunlich wenig.
Das könnte jetzt auch irgendwie eine Möwe sein,
die über den blauen Hinn ist.
Aber eine sehr hell leuchtende Möwe.
Ich mache mal einen Screenshot, dann können Sie.
Und dann hat mich meine Uhr gefragt,
hast du einen Sturz gehabt?
Und hat dich deine Riss in dem Moment auch gefragt?
Wenn du nicht innerhalb von 10 Sekunden antwortest,
hol ich einen Hubschrauber.
Ja, wirklich, genau so tut das.
Du bist kein Hubschrauber, bloß ein Notruf.
Also ich konnte mich, ich dachte mir so,
oh Gott, ich muss das jetzt hier schnell klicken,
bevor irgendwas passiert.
Aber ich hatte, glaube ich, nur die Wahl zwischen
ich bin gestürzt und mir geht es gut
oder ich bin gestürzt und mir geht es nicht gut.
Ich konnte nicht sagen, ich bin nicht gestürzt, glaube ich.
Aber ich muss es nochmal verifizieren.
Ich meine, du wirst es ja auch irgendwie
die Möglichkeiten limitieren und nicht überkomplizieren.
Ja, ich bin gestürzt,
mir geht es tendenziell eher gut,
aber ruf doch mal einen Notruf.
Aber nur, wenn ich 10 Minuten
jetzt nicht antworte oder so.
Also maximale Komplexität.
Spannende UI-Frage. Was bietet man Leuten
an, die gerade einen Unfall hatten?
So eine stufenlos skalierbare
Einstellung
von nichts passiert
bis tot.
Einen Storz zwischen 1 und 10
Mein Opa hat das ja letztendlich mal gehabt.
Der hat sich hingeschmissen in der Neustadt,
mit dem Fahrrad auf der Bordstarkante ausgerutscht hat
und mal Abhack oben.
und ist
hingefallen, hat sich den Kopf
angehauen, lag dann
kurz bewusstlos da für ein paar Sekunden.
Leute sind halt zu ihm hingekommen, wollten
helfen und haben einen Notruf gerufen und
der Notruf meinte halt bloß schon, ja, wissen schon
Bescheid, dem seine Uhr hat schon Bescheid
gegeben. What?
Da hat er all seinen Freunden in ähnlichem Alter
von der Wunder-Uhr berichtet,
die ihm das Leben bilden. Also ja, das beste wäre
ungefähr.
Ich bin auch sehr
beruhigt, dass meine Eltern solche
Dinger tragen. Die sind längst noch nicht in dem Alter,
aber ich hoffe, dass sie es dann in 20 Jahren
oder so, wenn sie es wirklich brauchen,
dann tatsächlich auch immer noch tragen. Ja, ich meine,
im Worst Case, dann fällst du zu Hause, alleine wohnt
die Treppe runter und dann, ja,
merkt das halt keiner für Partan.
Ich hatte neulich mit einem Kollegen darüber geredet, der sich
mit Home Automation
so einen
Notrufbutton für seinen Vater oder für
seinen Großvater selber gebastelt hat.
Es gibt ja diese Hausnotrufsysteme,
wo man als alte Person so einen Knopf drückt
und dann schreit einem so eine Sprechanlage in der Wohnung an.
Das ist immer sehr spannend.
Als TV bin ich auf solche Hausnummern,
muss ich reagieren.
Im schlimmsten Fall kommt da eine TV
und checkt, ob du wirklich einen Notarzt brauchst.
Das ist schon mal weird.
Das ist spannend, ja.
Aber die haben halt den Nachteil,
dass das deckt ist.
Und wenn du den Luxus hast,
ein größeres Grundstück
zu haben, kann es sein, dass du halt mit diesem
Knopf gerade außer Reichweite bist. Und da hat er
irgendwie mit diesem,
wie heißt er, dieses TTF
oder wie heißt er, dieses
Things Network.
Ich kenne die ganzen
Smart Home Sachen jetzt.
Mit dem,
mit Lorawan. Lorawan
läuft das? Okay, das ist cool.
Einen Knopf gebaut.
Und erstaunlich, was sicherlich
Overkill ist, die Reichweite.
angeht.
Von der anderen Seite der Stadt,
die Stadtgröße, aber da kannst du ja wirklich auf Kilometer.
Hast du mir mal erzählt, dass du was mit Lorawan gemacht hast?
Ich habe ja noch nie was mit Lorawan gebaut.
Lorawan, für die Leute, die es
kennen oder noch nicht kennen, ist glaube ich das,
was man nutzt, um Windkraftanlagen
miteinander zu verknüppern.
Ich habe Leihräder und so Kram, das sind Lorawan.
Also nicht alle, aber
die coolen. Also falls ihr
euch mit Lorawan auskennt,
kommt doch mal bitte zu Besuch in diese Sendung.
Lora Wahn für, steht das
für Long Range
World Area Network?
Ja, genau.
Das Lora steht für Long Range.
An dieser Stelle hört das auch für mich auf.
Impliziert das nicht schon das World Area
Network?
Ich glaube, es wäre trotzdem ein Wide Area Network.
Aber einfach mehr Longer.
Eine Weltkarte auf der
Weltkarte.
Also wenn ich es richtig gesagt habe,
sind es so 5 Kilometer
reichweilig. Also du kannst mit ein paar Sendern
eine Stadt covern, wenn du halt so ein
eigenes Netzwerk für beispielsweise
Laienfrau aufbauen möchtest. Aber es ist
nicht so, ob du von Dresden nach Leipzig mit Lora
wahnfunkst, ohne was dazwischen.
Also du musst auch, glaube ich, irgendwie
eine Subscription haben
und irgendwie Geld bezahlen, wenn du es benutzen willst.
Sei denn, du hast deinen eigenen Access Point
und dann meldest
auch einen an.
Du kannst dir Infra mieten?
Nee, du kannst es, glaube ich, irgendwie betreiben.
Also das ist jetzt wirklich zweiter Handwissen.
Aber der hat dann wie gemeint,
betreibt einen eigenen Access Point,
deswegen kann er es einfach so mitnutzen.
Ich betreibe einen Tor-Exit-Note,
deswegen darf ich das in der Check nutzen.
Das wäre auch witzig.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das war ja mal ein lustigeres Zeit.
Ja, wie sind wir da jetzt hingekommen? Ach so, über dein Gehirn
und über dein Knie.
Ach stimmt, beim Knie war das Abbiegen.
Oh je.
Ja, wir haben ein paar
coole Themen, aber trotzdem auf der Liste stehen.
ich mache jetzt mal eine absolut bescheuerte
Nichtsüberleitung hier.
Wir wollten ja ursprünglich mal mit dir
quatschen, Marc,
weil du mal gesagt hast,
du hast irgendwie Bock über Forgeo zu
quatschen.
Forgeo, ja.
Das war ein Esperanto-Begrepp, wenn ich mich richtig kenne.
Richtig.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Mach ich gleich.
Ich bin komplett raus.
Also wir reden über
Forgeo.
eigentlich wollte ich das schon
im Sommer 2022
also mal von euch
besprechen lassen, also es war ja nur
es ging im akronomisierbaren Chat
ging es darum
dass es mal wieder eine neue Sendung
stattfinden sollte und die
Leute im Chat haben die eingefordert und ich
hab dann noch dazu gedacht, ihr könnt auch übrigens
auch mal über das folgende Thema reden
zwei Jahre später
Hast du dir so gedacht, fuck it, I do it myself.
Nein, tatsächlich hat mich Kilian eingeladen und gefragt, ob ich mal darüber reden will,
weil es offenbar so klang, als ob ich der übelste Auskenner bin in dem Thema.
Du weißt schon, welcher Podcast das ist.
Geballtes, gefährliches Halbnis.
Ja, ja, ja.
Nee, tatsächlich war das eher so, dass ich mich mit dem Thema beschäftigt habe,
weil ich ein großer Freund der Dezentralisierung bin.
Geil.
Und ich hatte beruflich schon mit dem Hosten eines GitLab zu tun
und wollte das dann auch gerne für zu Hause haben
und fand das aber irgendwie zu klobig.
Also das ist halt ein Riesenkonstrukt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das auch schon mal von innen gesehen habt.
GitLab ist echt ein dickes Ding.
Ja, genau.
Das hat so ein bisschen Featureitis,
weil die Firma, die dahinter steht,
das als Produkt betreibt und dann immer
mehr noch draufgeschmissen. Richtig, genau.
Am Anfang klang immer wie so eine schöne
minimalistische, ganz großen Anführungsstrichen
GitHub-Alternative. Genau.
Und dann ist alles reingeführt. Ich habe das nochmal
versucht rauszufinden, aber irgendwie habe ich es nicht mehr gefunden.
Aber von GitLab habe ich das erste Mal gehört
bei einem Lightning-Talk auf den
Datenspuren, als die Datenspuren
noch in der Scheune waren. Hammer.
Und da hieß, also
ich erinnere mich noch so daran, wie die auf der Bühne
waren, meinten so, ja, hier, alle kennen ja GitHub
und das ist ja schön und gut und die promoten ja auch Open-Source-Software,
aber selber sind sie keine Open-Source-Software.
Stattdessen seht her, hier GitLab.
Und das habe ich mir gemerkt und als ich dann irgendwie...
Da hatten die noch ein Logo, was wie das GitHub-Logo aussah
und so ein bisschen Probleme dafür gekriegt haben.
Wir hatten ja auch mal so ein kleines Männchen irgendwie als Logo.
Diese waren erstaunlich ähnlich.
Ja.
Naja, jedenfalls habe ich das dann irgendwie dann auf Arbeit mal eingesetzt
und das war auch wirklich ganz gut und es hat irgendwie den Zweck erfüllt,
den wir da brauchten.
Aber für meinen kleinen Homeserver zu Hause war mir das trotzdem irgendwie ein bisschen zu fett.
Also meistens, glaube ich, dann eher Gitti, den Goxfork, weil das einfach sehr viel flacher ist.
Exakt, genau. Und da habe ich mir dann halt Gitti hergenommen und habe das da installiert.
Und das funktioniert auch tiptop.
Und das hat auch genau den richtigen Umfang für das, was ich halt so brauche.
Und habe aber parallel dazu, durch meine Affinität für Dezentralisierung,
auch schon immer auf das Issue, auf gitlab.com geguckt,
für wann denn mal Federation in GitLab eingebaut werden soll.
Und dieses Issue, das gibt es schon seit, ich will jetzt keine Zahl sagen, schon immer, sage ich mal.
Was heißt Federation im Git-Kontext?
Ich wollte gerade fragen, weil Git ist doch schon quasi ein dezentrales Versionierungssystem.
Ich kann doch von hier forken und nach da pushen.
Völlig richtig.
Nur...
Alles andere ist halt nicht federated.
So Issues und Kommentare.
Richtig, richtig, richtig, richtig.
Ah, okay.
Und also das Schlimme ist ja, dass viele Leute heutzutage denken,
wenn man Git sagt, dass man GitHub meint.
Ja, das ist echt ein bisschen zu sehr verknüpft.
Naja, da muss man halt schon ein bisschen erklären.
Und vor allen Dingen war ja auch dadurch,
diese ganzen
Services wie halt jetzt GitHub oder GitLab
oder auch GitT, dass die halt irgendwie so
omnipräsent sind im
Alltag bei der Softwareentwicklung,
haben sich auch eben alle an
die ganzen Features, die das eben über das
reine Git, Commit und Push und so
weiter hinaus halt irgendwie bietet, dran gewöhnt
und es ist ja auch sinnvoll, dass man halt
ein Issue direkt an
das
Git-Repo hängt und nicht irgendwie
darauf aufbauen muss. Das ist ein essentieller Teil des Workflows.
Richtig, genau. Früher hat man das ja per E-Mail gemacht, nicht wahr?
Man kann ja also Git auch Patches per E-Mail verschicken.
Git selber wird immer noch so entwickelt.
Selbstverständlich.
Dafür wurde es gebaut, ja.
Das heißt, deswegen heißt es ja auch Pull Request übrigens und nicht Merge Request.
Eigentlich auf GitHub müsste es Merge Request heißen.
Ja, ich mag den Begriff Pull Request auch nicht, weil man requestet ja keinen Pull.
Git Lab, da heißt es ja gleich umgetaucht zu. Wir machen es richtig.
Merge Request.
Genau, Pull Request kommt daher, dass ich einen Fork habe
möchte, dass du von meinem Fork pullst.
Ja.
So, und
bevor wir jetzt davon ablenken, aber also jetzt
wie spricht man es aus?
Man spricht es Forgeo aus.
Es gibt auf forgeo.org
slash FAQ. Also es schreibt sich
Forgeo.org.
Genau.
Und
ist inspired by
Forgeo, the Esperanto
Word for Forge steht in den FAQ
und da ist auch eine Audiodatei.
angehängt. Du schneidest
dann gleich nochmal.
Also Esperanto ist ja schon
eine designte Kunstsprache
und hat halt sehr viel Inspiration von den ganzen
romanischen Sprachen und auch ein bisschen
Deutsch und Englisch mit drin, weil es
fair sein sollte, aber halt nur fair,
was die westliche Welt angeht.
Da ist halt quasi überhaupt nichts eingeflossen von anderen Sprachen.
Und deswegen ist das Esperanto-Wort für Hund
beispielsweise auch Hundo.
Da ist das deutsche Äquivalent.
Sehr spannend.
So, ich drücke jetzt hier nochmal auf Play,
bei der Audiodatei.
Forgeo.
Kannst du ja da nochmal reinschneiden.
Die Ausprachregeln im Esperanto sind relativ simpel.
Da kann man sich mal kurz belesen,
dass es dann ein G mit so einem breit und typischen Kampen gibt.
Lass uns über Esperanto später reden.
Ja, völlig vom Thema weg.
Also Forgeo ist jetzt,
wenn ich es verstehen will,
du benutzt es quasi jetzt auf Arbeit bereits?
Nee.
Forgeo ist jetzt GitLab?
Warte mal, da bin ich noch gar nicht gewesen.
Das ist doch Teil der ganzen Geschichte.
Erzähl bitte weiter.
Okay, also.
Denn ich meine, dass das in dem Zusammenhang war,
dass Microsoft GitHub gekauft hat, akronomisierbar berichtet.
Also da bin ich mir jetzt aber nicht ganz so sicher,
ob das jetzt so direkt einen Zusammenhang hatte.
Auf jeden Fall hat sich in Berlin, glaube ich, sogar sitzen die,
einen Verein gegründet, der
Codeberg e.V. heißt.
Stimmt, Codeberg. Und der die Plattform
Codeberg.org anbietet,
was eine Instanz von
Gitti war.
Ah.
Die sich explizit irgendwie
darauf bezogen haben, jetzt einen
freien und wirklich auch immer
ordentlich freien und nicht irgendwann
mal zu Verkauf stehenden
eine Plattform anbieten
wollten, wo Leute eben auch ihr
Git-Kreppel liegen lassen können.
ohne irgendwelchen Corporate-Hintergrund.
Ich mag den Namen Codeberg
sehr. Ich weiß nicht so richtig, ob das
Codeberg, so wie Seudberg heißt.
Ja, das ist wahrscheinlich der Codeberg.
Ich denke auch, dass das Codeberg heißt.
Das sagt sich bei meinen Hörmacher direkt Codeberg draus,
aber so ein Berg aus Code, hier ist
die Halde, die Code-Halde.
Ja. Da ist übrigens unten drunter
viel mehr, als du an der Oberfläche siehst.
Oh je. Ja, 70%.
So, die haben, ist jetzt
Fort Geo, eine
Weiterentwicklung. Genau.
Genau. Also erstmal hat sich dieser Verein gegründet und hat dann irgendwie in dem Zusammenhang, dass sich dieser Verein gründet und dass dort eben eine Community sich angesiedelt hat und eben an diesem Gitti rum entwickelt hat.
Daraus ist dann irgendwie auch entstanden, dass sie sich nochmal ein bisschen expliziter mit dem Konzept der Federation beschäftigen wollen, weil es eben nicht so einfach ist, da jetzt irgendwie halt so ein Feature-Set aus dem Boden zu stampfen, was dann einfach so funktioniert, wie man das erwarten würde.
Und ja, da haben die dann halt dran rumfiel.
Irgendwie ist das dann so in diesem Sommer 2022 rum,
ist da irgendwie auf einmal ein bisschen mehr passiert.
Ich hatte so einen Mastodon-Account auch abonniert.
Und das habe ich zu dem Zeitpunkt gemacht,
hauptsächlich, weil ich da einfach immer alles,
was mich irgendwie halbwegs interessiert hat,
gefollowed hat, weil ich den Leuten dahinter dann zeigen wollte,
dass es Leute gibt im Fidiverse, die sich dafür interessieren.
Das war ja alles noch vor der ganzen Twitter-Implosion und so weiter.
Beziehungsweise 2022 war dann ja schon irgendwie so der erste Mask sagt, ich will Twitter kaufen.
Das zieht sich schon eine Weile her.
Jedenfalls kam da auf einmal plötzlich Aktivität und ich habe das dann immer so ein bisschen mehr mitbekommen
und habe festgestellt, da passiert langsam was.
Da machen sich Leute wirklich öffentlich Gedanken rum und fangen auch an zu coden.
Und ja, Mensch, geil, das scheint ja irgendwie mal zu klappen.
nachdem ich da schon seit fünf Jahren
auf dieses GitLab-Issue geguckt habe
und da einfach nichts passiert ist, was so Federation-Sachen angeht.
Und da war ich halt irgendwie
sehr interessiert daran,
wie das so weitergeht
und
habe das eben verfolgt. Und in dem Zusammenhang
habe ich auch gesagt, hier,
guckt euch das doch auch mal an und
redet darüber, weil ich finde es spannend.
Absurde Seiten,
Eine Seiteninfo wäre jetzt noch, dass die das Gitti aber auf GitHub entwickelt haben.
Also es gab zwar eine Gitti-Instanz, da stand aber irgendwie nur drauf,
es ist zum Testen und das kann in 24 Stunden wieder weg sein oder auch nicht.
Keine Ahnung, benutze es nicht produktiv.
Und ja, das ist auch irgendwie nie anders geworden.
Irgendwann haben sie das mal angekündigt, dass sie da irgendwie irgendwas hin migrieren.
Aber eigentlich war irgendwann alles, was sie hatten, schon auf ihrem eigenen.
Es gibt ja den Unterschied zwischen, ich habe diese Software und ich betreibe diesen Service.
Und ich habe schon verstehen, dass die Leute, die Gitti betreiben,
vielleicht nicht einen öffentlichen Service betreiben,
wo alle Leute ihre Code-Projekte hin hochladen wollen,
weil da schon mitschwingt.
Du musst es dann halt auch maintain.
Und die URLs müssen stabil bleiben.
Na, da gibt es doch irgendwie so den Begriff Dogfooding.
Ja, ja, also das muss ja nicht für alles offen sein,
aber für Gitti auf Gitti würde es sich halt schon anbieten.
Würde es sich schon anbieten, ja.
Genau.
Ja, und dann gab es halt aber irgendwie so einen großen Knall.
Und was, was halt irgendwie dadurch, dass ich das alles in meinen Feeds so alles mitbekommen habe,
dann für mich auch nochmal besonders spannend war,
dass plötzlich einer der Core-Entwickler sich überlegt hat, ein Unternehmen zu gründen.
Und weil er auf den ganzen Domains und so weiter saß,
hat er einfach die Domains dann offiziell diesem Unternehmen zur Verfügung gestellt
und die Namensrechte und so weiter und so fort
und hat das irgendwie mal eben so mehr oder weniger über Nacht beschlossen.
Ich mache jetzt eine Firma draus.
Aus was?
Aus Gitti.
Ach so.
Und dann war Gitti plötzlich nicht mehr...
Und dann war Gitti plötzlich nicht mehr so cool
und die ganze Community, die halt auch zu großen Teilen
eben irgendwie sich in dem Codeberg schon gesammelt hatte,
fand das nicht so toll.
Und was macht man in dem Fall?
Weil wir haben ja Open-Source-Software, man forked es.
Gitti ist ja auch ein Fork von Gox.
Richtig, ja.
Was aber, glaube ich, wegen Inaktivität gestorben ist.
Ja, oder irgendwie so wurde da auch gesagt,
dass da keine Lust hatte, manche Features einzubinden.
Oder irgendwie so.
War halt irgendwie, weiß ich nicht.
Auf jeden Fall hat die GT ja wirklich sehr viel mehr draus gemacht.
Na klar, genau.
Und ja, dann haben die das halt geforgt
und haben das dann jetzt quasi offiziell auf Codeberg
als Homeforge angesagt.
Und ab sofort wurde dann halt da weiterentwickelt.
Das war erst ein Soft Fork.
Und jetzt irgendwie im Februar vor anderthalb Monaten oder so
haben sie das dann auch erst zu einem richtigen Hard Fork umgebaut.
Was ist jetzt ein Unterschied zwischen einem Soft Fork?
Ein Soft Fork ist, dass du...
Du könntest wieder zurückmerchen, wenn du wolltest.
Ja, also du pullst von Upstream immer deren Entwicklungen mit rein und baust deine eigenen nur noch dazu. Und Hard Fork wäre jetzt eben, dass sich die Linien doch komplett trennen und du dann nur noch cherrypickst, wenn du irgendwie sicherheitsrelevante Sachen hast.
Aber das heißt, Forgeo ist auch definitiv ein Gitti-Fork.
Richtig.
Und um mal zurückzukommen zu der Motivation dahinter auch mit,
dass es dezentral läuft.
Heißt das, dass CodeWork als eine Instanz mit diversen anderen,
also ich finde, genauso wie ich jetzt, um mal die Mastodon-Analogie zu ziehen,
ich habe einen Account bei einem Mastodon-Server,
in meinem Fall auch bei Chaos.Social,
und ich kann aber mit meinem Account interagieren
mit anderen Mastodon-Servern über meinem Server hinweg.
Richtig, genau, so ist das gedacht.
Also das ist jetzt noch nicht so, dass das in Forgeo implementiert ist und funktioniert.
Aber da wollen sie hin.
Richtig, da wollen sie hin.
Das ist auf jeden Fall das eine große Projekt, an dem die ganze Zeit wie wild dran gearbeitet wird.
Neben dem, dass das Forgeo überhaupt weiterentwickelt wird.
Also seit dem Fork sind da auf jeden Fall noch Sachen dazugekommen, die es bei Gitty nicht gab.
Wie zum Beispiel so Pages.
Das kennt man auch von GitLab und von GitHub.
aber das ist jetzt auf, zumindest auf Codeberg
kann man auch Pages haben
mit Username
Codeberg.page
Also man ja liebt den Features von GitHub.
GitLab kann ja auch GitLab Pages, die nutze ich auch
Arbeit für diverse Kleinigkeiten immer wieder.
GitLab Pages meinst du? GitLab Pages, ja.
Aber ich meine, auf GitHub Pages betreibe
ich diverse Infrastruktur von
mir. Das ist schon fast das wichtigste Feature
von GitHub. Ja, wirklich, weil es
Free Hosting.
Aber das ist geil, dass 4G das mit eingebaut hat.
Das macht mich sehr glücklich. Das ist übrigens auch einer der
warum ich euch vorgeschlagen habe,
euch mal mit diesem Thema zu beschäftigen, weil
ihr mir oft
zu wenig kritisch mit diesen
zentralistischen Systemen umgeht.
Ein Problem, das ich habe, ist
GitHub als Firma,
ja, da definitiv
sehr viel Kritik abladen, aber es ist
halt schon
ein sehr,
wie formuliere ich das
am besten? Es ist eine Webseite,
die ich sehr viel frequentiere, weniger
aus dem Social-Aspekt heraus,
Aber vor allem, weil sie mir meine Home-Timeline kaputt gemacht haben,
ist auf Dauer ein Staderschrott geworden.
Aber ich mag es schon.
Eddification.
Ja, aber wirklich, Eddits finest wieder.
Aber ich mag es halt schon.
Ich habe da ein Account.
Ich kann Issues bei anderen Leuten aufmachen.
Und ich meine, Stars hin oder her.
Es ist halt schon irgendwie, ja, GitHub ist halt der Ort,
wo die meisten Sachen auch, also klar, Forks können auch woanders liegen.
Aber da liegt halt meistens der Original Source, in Anführungsstrichen.
Was bedeutet das denn eigentlich?
Aber das ist halt der Ort, wo dann die Interaktion passiert.
Da mache ich den Pull-Request auf oder da mache ich das Issue auf.
Und das Problem an so kleinen Gitti-Instanzen ist halt,
dass die, ja, die leben halt für sich.
Und wenn ich eine Gitti-Instanz auf meinem Server aufmache,
dann wird mir da zum einen niemals jemand ein Issue aufmachen,
weil das keines auch findet.
Und zum anderen auch nicht,
weil ich natürlich keine Registration auf meinem Server habe.
Deswegen ist es ja so, dass du dich bei GitLab
und übrigens auch bei Codeberg
mit deinem GitHub-Account einloggen kannst.
Das ist ein nettes Lieder.
Ich mag Social Login zu brauchen.
Und deswegen arbeiten die Leute gerade daran,
Federation für Git-Repos zu erfinden und zu implementieren,
um genau dieses Problem zu überwinden.
Ja, das macht es endlich möglich.
Richtig, genau.
Also, um mal die abstrakte Kritik an GitHub
und an der Tatsache, dass GitHub eine Instanz ist,
mal etwas weniger abstrakt zu machen.
Was ist denn die Kritik daran, dass GitHub...
Weil GitHub eine schreckliche Firma...
Also zum einen, ja klar, es ist Microsoft dahinter.
Es gibt eine schreckliche Firma.
Früher war das Hauptargument immer die ganze Eis-Sache,
dass ich mit Eis zusammenarbeite.
Das kam immer hoch.
Heutzutage ist das meiner Meinung nach eines der wichtigsten Kriterien immer noch,
dass Microsoft dahinter steht,
Microsoft Zugang zu all deinen privaten Repos hat,
Microsoft all deine private Daten nutzt,
um Machine Learning oder AI anzutrainieren,
ob du das willst oder nicht,
und deine Daten jetzt in Copilot mit reingeflossen sind,
ob du das willst oder nicht.
Und da hast du nicht wirklich eine Kontrolle darüber.
Ich habe auf GitHub auch einige Sachen in privaten Repos liegen,
die definitiv nicht auf GitHub liegen sollten.
Zum Beispiel, also...
Jetzt kommt es raus.
Nee, aber das ist das Unkritischste, was ich sagen kann.
Vielleicht mal ein paar Config-Dateien für diverse Services von mir.
Und da sind auch wenig Credentials gehardcoded,
aber da gibt es definitiv ein paar Sachen,
die berechtfertigen, dass das Ding kein Public-Repo ist,
sondern ein Private-Repo.
Aber Private heißt halt in dem Kontext,
privat für mich und Microsoft.
Nicht nur für mich.
Also deine Frage zielt dir jetzt möglicherweise
ein bisschen zu sehr dahin,
warum GitHub jetzt ausgerechnet böse ist oder so.
Ich würde das aber ein bisschen allgemeiner formulieren.
Und da muss ich mal wieder Elon Musk danken,
dass er mir so ein wunderschönes Beispiel geliefert hat.
Der Twitter-Moment könnte halt jederzeit passieren.
Der könnte jederzeit liefern und passieren.
Und das ist ja meiner Meinung nach,
wäre das für GitHub noch viel, viel, viel schlimmer,
als es für Twitter der Fall war.
Im Endeffekt ist ja genau das passiert.
NixOS könnte man zum Beispiel wegwerfen,
weil es einfach nicht mehr funktionieren würde,
weil alle Leute da ausschließlich drauf hängen.
Und das ist nicht das einzige Beispiel.
Package Manager, Home-Uli.
Alles Mögliche ist sowas von auf GitHub genagelt.
Es ist ja passiert.
GitHub war eine eigenständige Firma,
die nicht so neulich profitable war,
aber mittlerweile wirklich zu einem Backbone
für das Internet an vier Stellen geworden ist.
Definitiv.
Und die waren in einer Schieflage.
Und was man Microsoft zugutehalten muss,
ist, sie haben es jetzt gekauft.
und... In welchem Teil des
Embrace Extinguished Cycles
sind wir egal. Und bislang
ist nicht so viel Schlimmes
passiert, weil Microsoft
vornehmlich ein Interesse daran hat,
dieses Open-Source-Ökosystem
offenbar, wo sie sich ja sehr
darauf konzentrieren in den letzten Jahren, wo sie
auch sehr von profitieren in den letzten Jahren,
einfach laufen zu lassen. Aber das ist genau der Punkt.
Aktuell denken wir und
hoffen und wahrscheinlich alignen
unsere Incentives zu einem gewissen Punkt,
Aber das kann per Definition nicht für immer der Fall sein.
Und was ist dann?
Also momentan können wir einfach uns zurücklehnen und uns denken,
es ist eigentlich ganz gut,
dass Microsoft noch unsere Interessen teilt, was GitHub angeht.
Hoffentlich, also von dem, was wir vermuten,
von öffentlichem Wissen heraus.
Aber es kann sein, dass es in ihre AI-Strategie 2025 nicht mehr reinpasst
und sie sich denken, okay, ihr habt jetzt entweder Public-Repos
oder wir löschen das jetzt alles.
Apropos, ich habe vorhin gerade mal kurz nachgeschaut.
Und dann, in dem Moment wäre es gut, wenn die Federation in dezentralen Systemen so weit fortgeschritten wäre,
dass man dann sagen könnte, wie der Twitter-Mastodon-Moment.
Jetzt gehen alle in die dezentralisierte Welt und benutzen das Internet so, wie es eigentlich gedacht ist.
Das ist ein sehr schöner Punkt.
Bei Mastodon war auch sehr praktisch, dass es schon da war, als wir von Twitter weg wollten.
Gut, viele von uns hatten schon ihre Mastodon-Account, weil wir es halt vorher schon mal ausprobiert hatten.
aber es war da und musste nicht zu dem Zeitpunkt händeringend entwickelt werden,
weil wir eine Alternative brauchten.
Und es wäre auch schön, wenn sowas hier,
also ich möchte nicht unterstellen, dass Mastodon eine einfache Implementierung ist,
aber gerade ein dezentrales Git und alles, was da halt noch mit dranhängt,
das klingt für mich noch ein bisschen komplexer als in Anführungsstrichen nur Microblogging.
Bei Mastodon kommen noch ein paar komplizierende Faktoren mit dazu.
Zum einen ist Mastodon eine Implementierung von ActivityPub.
Nicht mal unbedingt eine nicht kontroverse Implementierung von ActivityPub,
weil sie einen gewissen Marktanteil haben
und dadurch auch eine gewisse Implementierungsmarktmacht haben.
Sie haben, wie ich das mitbekommen habe,
ich glaube, es ging um Editing oder Kommentierfunktionen.
Da haben sie einfach Features so implementiert, wie sie wollten
und sich nicht an den Standard gehalten
oder etwas implementiert.
was nicht explizit
spezifiziert war und das in ihrem
Client und ihrem Webinterface auch
mit angeboten als Feature. Damit ist die
Spec in die Richtung geboten worden.
Damit quasi die Spec mit Gewalt in die
Richtung gedrückt. Das ist quasi
wie es mittlerweile bei Webstandards ist, das ist
nicht mehr ein Standard, an den sich alle Browser
halten, sondern das wird quasi an vielen Stellen
einfach rückwirkend standardisiert,
was Chrome in seinen Browser
einbaut. Ja, absolut.
Und sowas kann dir halt auch passieren.
Bei Masudan kam noch dazu,
es sind nicht alle auf Mastodon gesprungen
und
der, wie hieß er, der ursprüngliche
Chef von Twitter hat Blue Sky gegründet.
Check durch sie, ja.
Die federaten mittlerweile mit
Mastodon, meinetwegen, aber es gibt
oder war es Threads?
Dann gibt es Threads.
Aber
vielleicht
ist das ja bei
Forgeo
ein bisschen
hoffentlich besser. Also wie gesagt, das ist noch nicht fertig,
das ist immer noch in Entwicklung und steht da,
man kann schon irgendwas anschalten. Ich habe das auch
angeschaltet in meinem, aber ich habe keinen Unterschied
bemerkt. Also erzähl uns das mal ganz kurz.
Ich habe noch eine Frage noch dazu.
Ist es so, dass Forgeo eigentlich
dann auch ActivityPub mit implementiert?
Also könnte ich einem Issue folgen mit meinem Master?
Das wäre das, was ich jetzt frage.
Also es ist, also
diese
ForgeFed ist
eine Extension vom ActivityPub.
So dass eben,
Also das spricht dann auch ActivityPub mit anderen Forgeo-Instanzen.
Und dann eben einen besonderen Dialekt,
wo es eben um Issues und so weiter geht
und eben nicht um Posts und Bilder.
Tiefer ins Detail kann ich da jetzt aber auch nicht aus dem Kopf reingehen.
Ich habe den Fortschritt-Link mal mit reingepackt.
Das wäre jetzt meine Frage gewesen.
Forgeo ist ein federatierbares GitHub-Äquivalent.
Zoom.
zu. Es ist,
es gibt, soweit ich weiß,
zumindest diese eine Implementierung.
Es gibt eine
Speck, die heißt ForgeFed und der Link
heißt ForgeFed.org.
Und das Link ist 1 zu 1
das Home Assistant Logo.
Stimmt, das ist
das gleiche Logo.
Nur um eine Brücke zurückzuschlagen
zu
unserer
letzten Folge.
Es ist wirklich 1 zu 1 dasselbe Logo.
Das ist wirklich
Pixel Perfect, nur andere Farben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da nicht schon der erste Rechtsstreit
läuft.
Aber es ist halt auch das Home-Message-Logo,
hat halt auch dieses Git-Branch-Dings in der Mitte
getroffen. Genau.
Das ist mir noch nicht aufgefallen, das ist ja bescheuert.
Aber welches,
welche Feature bietet
das jetzt an? Also Activity Pub,
da kann ich Leuten folgen, das kann man bei GitHub.
Ich sehe Activities
von denen, was die gemacht haben, geliked, gestarrt,
gepublished,
geforkt,
Issues geöffnet haben.
Und dann ist quasi ein Issue so eine Art
Post oder was?
Ein Pull-Request ist so eine Art Post als Threat
und jeder...
Ja, da stellst du mir jetzt Fragen, die ich nicht so genau beantworten kann.
Ich vermute, dass das auch so ist. Ich hab's mir aber, wie gesagt,
noch nicht so im Detail angeguckt, weil ich
eigentlich darauf warte, dass in dem Blog-Post
irgendwann steht, jetzt ist es
ready, jetzt könnt ihr das alle benutzen
und so funktioniert's übrigens.
Und dadurch, dass ich das alles so mehr oder weniger in Production verwende, will ich da auch nicht immer so die Latest Nightly Builds installieren und irgendwie rumfummeln, weil dann kommt meine Frau an und sagt, hier, der Passwortmanager geht nicht mehr.
Wo betreibst du es denn jetzt? Betreibst du es auf Arbeit oder auf deinem?
Auf meinem Homeserver.
Alles klar. Also die Referenzimplementierung von ForgeFed wird hier aufgeräumtiert und heißt Vervis.
Ich habe übrigens gerade mal gesucht, ob ich eine Referenz finde von beiden Projekten, Logo, ob das irgendjemand mal angesprochen hat.
Es ging schnell.
Es gibt keine Unterhaltung dazu, die ich finden kann.
Und einer der, ich habe dann Google versucht,
ob da oder andere Treffer sind,
sind der einzige Treffer für sowohl Home Assistant als auch ForgeFed.
Oder einer von dreien.
Ist unser Podcast.
Anscheinend haben wir ForgeFed schon mal verlinkt,
aber nur im Feed, weil ich finde die Folge dazu nicht.
Spannend.
Aber Google hat es im Feed indiziert.
Okay.
Ich habe ja manchmal Angst, dass wir über Themen einfach mehrmals reden,
weil ich mich nicht mehr daran erinnere,
was wir vor zehn Folgen gesagt haben.
Oder das liest auch den Chat,
weil da hatte ich es ja verlinkt damals.
Nee, da war gar nicht der RSS-Feed.
Aber das ist ja in der Future-Folge, in dieser Folge.
Hast du nicht die Transcripts irgendwo mal hochgeladen gehabt?
Nee, nee, abgesehen davon, dass die nie wirklich gut geklappt haben,
gibt es die auch nicht, obwohl, die liegen vielleicht auf Archive.org einfach.
Also, es gibt ForgeFed und gibt es da jetzt außer CodePerk schon irgendwelche Instanzen von, die...
Ja, ganz viele. Also ich kann dir jetzt keine besondere sagen, außer vielleicht noch die vom C3D2, die man auch benutzen kann, wenn man da irgendwie...
Das ist auch ein Forgeo.
Das ist noch ein Gitti und an alle administrativ...
Wie heißt die Adresse davon?
C3D2.de?
Ja, denke schon. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Public ist.
ist er public.
Aber du brauchst ein Account.
Aber das könnten die ja auch mal updaten.
Weil ich glaube, an dem Gitti
ist seitdem auch nicht mehr ganz so viel
passiert, obwohl vielleicht...
Keine Ahnung, aber ich meine, ich habe das Gitti in den letzten Wochen
immer wieder genutzt gehabt. Also es wird
rege genutzt. Es gab ein bisschen
Unterhaltung dazu, ob da Leute auch private
Sachen halten dürfen, mit einem
sehr lauten Nein von
diversen Leuten aus dem Space.
Kann ich auch in gewisser Weise
verstehen, aber ob da jetzt Dot-Files liegen oder nicht,
who cares. Das ist so, ich packe bitte
nicht deine Binary-Blobs auf diese Share-Infra.
Naja, für so Dot-Files habe ich schon
gerne meine eigene. Ja, absolut.
Ich verteile die gerne noch so ein bisschen, so infektiöse
Dot-Files, einfach nur damit sie auch
woanders liegen, falls ich sie mal suche.
Ja.
Genau, so. Also eigentlich
wollte ich das mit der Federation erst ganz am Ende erzählen,
weil ich nämlich noch erzählen wollte, dass es neben Pages
auch inzwischen
Actions gibt, so wie bei
GitHub auch und bei GitLab
hieß es ja einfach nur CI-CD, genau.
Und das hatte das auch schon,
also nee, das hatte nicht das Gitti schon, sondern man konnte
Gitti verknüpfen mit so einer CI-Software, mit
auch mehreren Software, nehmen wir an, dass es da auch irgendwie so eine Art
Standardprotokoll gibt. Jedenfalls konnte man das mit
einer Software namens Drone verbinden.
Stimmt.
Die hatte dann aber auch irgendwann diesen Moment,
dass es plötzlich irgendwie kommerziell werden sollte.
Und dann gab es da auch noch irgendwie einen Fork,
von der Woodpecker CI hieß.
Und das war aber irgendwie so ein bisschen fummelig.
Ich hatte das irgendwann bei mir auch hinbekommen
und habe dann da irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
so zwei, drei Sachen mitgemacht.
Aber jetzt privat brauche ich jetzt nicht wirklich so viel CI.
Also können wir schon einige Sachen machen,
Aber inzwischen habe ich das
vor Geo-Actions auch
bei mir an, weil man
jetzt inzwischen nur noch, wie man das von GitLab
kennt, so einen Runner irgendwo hin installieren
muss. Dann konfiguriert man da
die Verbindung und dann spricht das nur
HTTPS.
Das heißt, der Runner läuft bei dir auf einer anderen
Maschine als da, wo das Posting
läuft. Es läuft tatsächlich alles auf der
gleichen Maschine. Das ist aber nicht dafür gedacht.
Okay, aber man kann es auch so betreiben.
Wie funktioniert die Action?
man kriegt dann einfach einen Docker-File, oder?
Nee, also
wenn du pusht, wird halt
ein Ping
an den Runner, der auf
irgendeinem anderen Server liegt,
vielleicht auch dem eigenen gesendet, und dann fängt
der an, sich das Repo zu pullen,
und baut dann das da drin, was
eben die jeweilige Actions-Config
ihm sagt. Und das ist
auch in
Container.
Ich kann das jetzt auch nicht so genau wiedergeben, weil in der Doku steht, dass sie da LXC verwenden. Ich habe aber trotzdem bei mir alles irgendwie nur mit Docker gemacht, aber wie das da jetzt tiefer unten drunter aussieht, da kann ich jetzt auch nicht genau so viel zu sagen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass es einfacher geworden ist,
das zu implementieren, als es vorher war.
Man kann es ja zum Beispiel auch so machen,
dass man den Runner auf dem eigenen Laptop laufen lässt
und dann nur einmal, wenn man irgendwas testen will,
das dahin pusht und dann kommt es halt wieder zurück.
Das habe ich bei einem alten Job gemacht.
Da lief die CI auf dem Desktop unseres CEOs unter seinem Schreibtisch.
Ich hatte dazu ein SSH-Login, um die CI zu machen.
Das ist gut.
Der Rest der Infra.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, wir liefen einfach auf gitlab.com
hatten da als die iRunner seinen Desktop
mit reingebracht oder so.
Das war ein weirdes. Ja, genau.
Cool. Ich habe also jetzt einen
CodeWork-Account.
Vielleicht probiere ich das mal
ein bisschen aus. Aber das Problem, was halt auftritt,
ist, also auch eines der Hauptfeatures
von GitHub
ist ja
die Zentralität. Eigentlich das Hauptfeature
von GitHub
mit allen Pro und Cons ist die
Zentralität und damit
Visibility, die man damit kriegt. Man kann immer mal
erstmal davon ausgehen, wenn man irgendwas sucht,
wird schon auf GitHub liegen.
So, jetzt ist, wie geht
man jetzt damit um, dass es
dieses kleine Fativerse gibt, wo alles
miteinander verknüpft ist, aber GitHub
macht das potenziell nicht. Hat man dann
einen Visibility
Fork auf GitHub,
dann denke ich mir immer, wenn Leute jetzt
Issues aufmachen wollen. Na, man kann ja
Issues zumachen, aber also
du gehst jetzt immer auf
github.com und suchst dort direkt nach
den jeweiligen Projekten, weil ich gehe einfach in
meine Suchmaschine und finde dann im Zweifelsfall
das Projekt auf GitHub. Ich habe aber
gerade in den letzten Monaten häufiger gesehen,
dass wenn ich irgendwas suche, dass ich dann eben
auch Gitti bzw.
Forgeo Instanzen finde, weil die
offenbar auch sehr gut von den Suchmaschinen
erkannt und gelesen werden.
Und so funktioniert das ja auch.
Und wie du schon sagst, wenn das dann mit dem Activity
Pub alles so funktioniert, dann kannst du auch in deinem
Fedi-Feed
dir Releases oder
Commits oder was auch
immer du möchtest, dann da followen.
Wie das jetzt im Detail implementiert
ist, das ist ja, glaube ich, das, woran die gerade sitzen
und das ist ja nicht so einfach, weil es ist ja eben
ein Release zu abonnieren, ist ja noch
einfach, aber wenn du jetzt da filigraner
ins Detail gehen willst. Eigentlich möchte ich auch gar nicht so einem Gitterprojekt
auf Mastodon oder mit einem Mastodon
Client folgen. Releases folgen würde ich schon bei
manchen Sachen gerne. Das wäre schon cool.
Vor allem die dann teilen und dann
Stimmt, stimmt. Du kriegst auch gleich die Social Interaction mit rein.
Das ist ja auch was, was ich mal basteln wollte.
Wenn ich unsere Webseite nochmal neu mache,
dann kriegt die auf jeden Fall direkt
der Activity Pub Integration. Du hast sie dieses Jahr
noch nicht neu gebaut. Du hast sie letztes Jahr erst neu gebaut.
Stimmt. Aber dann werden
halt Seiten auch direkt
Post-Äquivalente sein,
die du dann direkt teilen kannst. Aktuell posten wir die halt
manuell. Aber sowas kannst du halt dann direkt
machen. Dann werden Releases, werden Posts,
Commits werden Posts, Issues werden Posts,
Issue Comments sind Replies darauf.
Und du kannst dann auch nicht schreiben mit deinem Mastodon-Account,
in dem du ein Reply drunter setzt.
Was wahrscheinlich zu sehr viel Spam führen würde.
Aber da kann man bestimmt irgendwie sinnvoll mit umgehen.
Dann hast du aber trotzdem ein Activity-Pub,
sagen wir Codeberg-Account,
und ein Activity-Pub Mastodon-Account.
Das zu vereinen ist generell noch so ein bisschen witzig.
Ich nutze ja auch diverse Plattformen aktuell.
Das ist nämlich das nächste Problem, was ich aufzählen wollte eigentlich,
was man bei Mastodon hat.
Verifizierung.
ich habe mir jetzt ein Code, also
Codeberg.org
Org? Org
Slash Holi. Ich folg dir schon.
Bin ich.
Ich sehe da jetzt nur vergrastet.
Aber wenn sich jetzt,
wenn sich
Codeberg.com
irgendjemand schnappt oder Codeberg.io
und da irgendwie
meine Sachen forkt, aber dann
irgendwas einschleicht und die Leute sich ausfüllen.
Na, du siehst doch anhand den Commits, dass du
die mit deinem GPG-Schlüssel
signiert hast und dass das nur du
sein kannst. Macht ihr das?
Ja.
Nicht mehr.
Also ich mach das schon.
Krupp.com ist übrigens ein Freis, aber eine Premium-Domain
kostet bei Namecheap
3.500.
Fürs erste Jahr. Renews at 14 Dollar.
Euro.
Aber
ich meine, wie habt ihr das Problem
gelöst? Ich könnte mich jetzt als
Kilian Kö auf allen möglichen
Mastodon-Servern
Ja, und teilweise machst du aber deinen eigenen auf.
Und da hast du dann den Reden Namespace frei.
Also ursprünglich ist ja die digitale Identität einer Person,
eines Unternehmens, einer Institution an sich so,
meiner Meinung nach die Webseite.
Und dann, wenn du irgendwie eine Verifikation von einer Person
oder einem Unternehmen oder was weiß ich willst,
dann gehst du auf die Webseite und dann klickst du auf der Webseite,
auf den Link zu dem...
Und genauso funktioniert Verifikation ja auch in Mastodon irgendwie.
Ich habe meinen Link auf meiner Webseite.
wo ein Link zu meinem Mastodon steht
und deswegen sagt mein Mastodon-Account,
das ist auch derselbe Typ, dem Hoodie.de gehört.
Das macht übrigens auch GitHub gehostet.
Ja, aber GitHub macht übrigens bei The Way
auch der Mastodon-Verification gleich mit.
Wenn du dein Mastodon-Account in deinem GitHub-Profil einträgst,
dann schauen die, ob da der Backlink vorhanden ist.
Also ist die Verifikation eigentlich insofern eher safe dadurch,
dass ich Mastodon habe, um GitHub zu verifizieren?
Weil wenn Microsoft morgen sagt,
Weißt du was? Wir modifizieren jetzt mal die Inhalte von dem einen Nutzer da.
Die Frage ist ja, was ist eigentlich jetzt das Trust-Level, was du ansprichst?
Also vertraust du jetzt deinem GitHub-Account, weil das halt auf GitHub ist?
Oder kann ich dem vertrauen?
Also GitHub ist eine große Institution, die, ich glaube zwar,
also man könnte bei solchen Sachen immer sagen, eine große Institution,
die möchte sich diesen Shitstorm nicht einfangen,
irgendwo an Leuten rumzudoktern.
Das hat man von Twitter auch gedacht bis vor zwei Jahren.
Aber das ist ja gar nicht mal das Problem.
Das Problem ist, was wir vorhin hatten,
dass allein diese Gefahr besteht.
Und theoretisch kann ja jeder daherkommen
und sich bei GitHub, in Anführungsstrichen,
einfach einhacken und Shit-Duder treiben.
Dich hält nichts davon ab,
bis auf das GitHub-Security-Team natürlich.
Aber prinzipiell, es ist trotzdem ein Single-Point-of-Failure.
Und ob das jetzt geplante
Instification ist oder Security
Vulnerabilities oder irgendwas, was damit
kaputt geht, Dinge können sich
spontan ändern.
Sehr schnell.
Also haben wir lieber alle noch einen
alternativen Fork unserer Projekte
auf Codeberg.
Oder Self-hosted dann.
Das ist ja die Kritik, die ich
bei Matrix oder bei
Mastodon halt vornehmlich sehe.
Du kannst ja nicht von jedem
verlangen, das Self-host zu hosten.
Und dieses, dann mach doch deinen eigenen, ist halt ein ganz schöner Aufruf. Das kannst du erstens einem Großteil der Bevölkerung nicht zumuten. Und zum anderen kommt dann halt dazu, okay, wenn ich jetzt nicht das selber hosten kann, ich könnte wahrscheinlich mein eigenes Mastodon hosten, aber ich habe keinen Bock drauf, dann hast du als nächstes dieses Problem, gut, okay, wo gehe ich denn hin?
und dann gibt es Webseiten für Mastodon
mit all den Instanzen
und dann hast du dieses Entscheidungsproblem.
Zu welcher Instanz gehe ich
und welche davon ist vertrauenswürdig?
Da gibt es welche, die heißen wie meine Stadt,
aber bloß, weil die wie meine Stadt heißen,
ich soll da hingehen.
Wenn die von der offiziellen Webseite deiner Stadt verlinkt sind,
dann kannst du wohl davon ausgehen,
wenn das auch eine HTTPS-Adresse ist.
Ich möchte aber an der Stelle eine Stange abbrechen,
dass Dresden.network ein sehr, sehr toller Server ist
Und wir haben etliche Hörer und Hörerinnen von Dresden.network.
Und ich weiß auch, dass bestimmte gewisse Mods hier zuhören.
Ich sage ja nur, Dresden.network ist ein super Mastodon-Server.
Aber an sich ist ja nicht official.
Da hast du absolut recht.
Aber ich könnte auch morgen einen aufmachen,
der Dresden.Social oder Dresden.AI heißt.
Du musst dich ja auch nicht unbedingt identifizieren
mit deiner Stadt auf der Ebene.
Aber du hast schon einen wichtigen Punkt,
dass Institutionen prima dafür
die Uni zum Beispiel.
Ich würde auf einem Mastodon-Server
oder auf einem
Matrix-Server
der TU Dresden
Ich meine, ich habe gerade gesagt, dass die Uni
prima dafür wäre und ich stehe auch
zum gewissen Punkt zu dieser Aussage, aber das
eine große Problem, was gerade die TU Dresden
damit macht, also abgesehen davon, dass sie
echt viel Mühe und Zeit und Geld auch mit
reinstecken in die Entwicklung solcher Tuts, die TU Dresden
hat schon richtig viel Geld auch in Matrix gesteckt,
also wirklich geltet Matrix, immer noch geil,
aber die TU Dresden ist halt
die Institution, die deinen Account sperren, wenn du da nicht mehr
arbeitest oder Student bist. Und das ist
große Scheiße. Gut, Mastodon kannst
du erstaunlich einfach umziehen, aber du musst es
trotzdem tun. Dein Matrix-Account ist einfach
weg. Dein E-Mail-Account ist einfach
au! Tut dir nicht weh.
Du musst nicht so große Gesten machen,
die Leute sehen das eh nicht.
Moment, also ich weiß,
dass deine ID
und deine E-Mail sperren.
Und das kann ich auch irgendwie nachvollziehen.
Zumindest vor ein paar Jahren waren diese Ressourcen irgendwo keins.
Der Matrix-Account ist dann auch,
also der ist, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, nicht weg.
Aber du kannst nicht mehr drauf zugreifen,
weil du dich ja über das IDM daran anmeldest
und dann kommst du ja nicht mehr ran.
Ich würde vermuten, dass die das nicht automatisiert wegmachen.
Das könnte sein.
Es gibt ja diesen Synapse-Admin,
wo man dann irgendwie wegklicken kann.
Vielleicht haben die sich auch was Automatisches geschrieben.
Das wurde relativ früh schon automatisiert.
Es war zu Anfangszeit des Matrix-Server
auf jeden Fall schon Thema, wie werden die alten Accounts
abgeräumt. Ich erinnere mich an lustige
Unterhaltung, weil das damals eine sehr kurze
Whitelist, als der Matrix-Server der TU
zuerst gefederated hat,
waren auf dieser Whitelist fünf Server,
unter anderem der von Johannes und der von mir.
Das war witzig, bevor er komplett offen war.
Also die ganzen Leute,
sobald sie promoviert oder ihren
Abschluss gemacht haben,
auf alumni.tu Dresden
oder sowas. Das wäre nett. Also die müssten natürlich
schon Infrazahlen, gar keine Frage, kostet das auch
Geld und Admin-Ressourcen, gar keine Frage.
Aber, also ich finde immer noch eines der
kritischsten, dass du Leuten E-Mail wegnimmst,
weil E-Mail halt wirklich so ein Ding ist, wo du
sehr viel dran kettest.
Alle deine Logins hängen an deinem E-Mail-Account. Du musst
wirklich neuen Studenten und Studentinnen sagen,
nutz den E-Mail-Account der Uni für Dinge,
aber vielleicht nicht als euren Haupt-
Account für die Accounts, wo
ihr euch neu anmeldet und Kram,
weil irgendwann wird der euch einfach weggenommen.
Und blöderweise passiert das auch so ein bisschen
über Nacht. Es ist nicht so von wegen,
hier, dein Account ist übrigens zwei Wochen nicht mehr da.
Dein Account ist übrigens sieben Tage nicht mehr da.
Du kriegst mal
Reminder und wenn es die geben, müssen die Leute
das halt mitkriegen. Aber
du kriegst halt irgendwann einfach den Login nicht mehr.
Und das ist schon echt scheiße.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber ich meine,
eigentlich kann man sich ja schon dessen bewusst sein,
wenn man nicht mehr
an der Uni ist, dass man dann auch nicht mehr
diese E-Mail-Adresse hat. Ja, aber das ist halt so ein Punkt,
da denkst du vielleicht erstmalig drüber nach,
so ein Jahr vor deinem Abschluss.
Und dann musst du aber Migrationsaufwand reinstecken.
Also man kann auf jeden Fall eine Weiterleitung einrichten,
die dann auch bestehen bleibt.
Das steht in irgendwelchen Sachen.
Irgendwo in den AGBs, wollte ich sagen, aber das stimmt nicht.
Das löst fast einmal in den Problem.
Bei E-Mail ist das nice.
Und so eine E-Mail-Weiterleitung ist ja auch relativ einfach gebaut.
Da mache ich irgendwie einen Bounce in dem Protokoll
und sage, nee, schick das mal an den.
Ja, aber das gibt es Matrix halt nicht.
Das ist ein 302 oder 301.
aber mit Matrix geht das vielleicht sogar auch irgendwie schlau.
Aber was ist mit, ich hoste meinen Code auf forgeo.thudresden.de?
Ja, warte mal, warte mal.
Das hält ja nicht forgeo.thudresden.de,
weil jetzt TU Dresden schon die perfekte Subdomain dafür hat,
nämlich das uralte Fusion Forge.
Fusion Forgeo.
Ja, ich würde es trotzdem git.thudresden.de nennen,
weil ich hatte nämlich meinen Server auch erst mit GITI Punkt
und dann musste ich das alles umbenennen,
als es ja plötzlich kein GITI mehr war.
Und das fand ich irgendwie doof.
Soll ich das Pass aufmachen,
dass man vielleicht solche Plattformen
nicht ausschließlich mit Git betreiben möchte,
sondern potenziell alternative Resonierungstools?
Ach stimmt, die TU Dresden hat, Tommy, Random Society.
Die TU Dresden hatten ja ein Fusion Forge.
Das war aber bloß das Fusion Forge der TU Chemnitz,
das genutzt wurde.
Mittlerweile ist es ein GitLab,
der TU Chemnitz auf das verlinkt wird.
Richtig.
Aber du hast da auf jeden Fall schon was angesprochen,
was ich sagen wollte, dass es eben
in Matrix noch nicht so einfach gelöst
ist, wie es
zumindest wie man hört mit Mastodon
der Fall ist, dass man relativ einfach irgendwie so eine
Datei exportieren kann, die man woanders importiert
und dann hast du zumindest irgendwie
Follower und so weiter. Ich hab's
noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Hast du ein Matrix-Account umziehen?
Nee, ein Mastodon-Account umziehen.
Das hab ich gemacht. Das ist erstaunlich sinnlos.
Sinnlos?
Also du ziehst nichts um,
du zwingst bloß alle Leute, die dem alten Account
gefolgt haben, dem neuen Account zu folgen.
Ja, aber das ist doch gerade das, was das Hauptproblem ist.
Dass du halt danach, du willst ja
nicht von neu anfangen, weil du kriegst
nicht die Leute, allen Leuten mitgeteilt, dass du jetzt
da abdrüben bist.
Und alte Sachen sind ja trotzdem
passiert und alte Sachen sind auf alte
Domains verlinkt und du willst ja jetzt nicht
irgendwie rekursiv das ganze Internet auf
deinen neuen Macedon-Account umgeben.
Nee, es gab irgendwie Diskussionen, sollten da vielleicht
alte Posts umgezogen werden
Das ist ein Argument, ja.
Da gibt es halt ganz viele, die sagen,
nee, weil
du kannst es plötzlich halt
benutzen, um
Massen-Imports auf
irgendwelche Server zu machen, um
historische Posts,
die du nie gemacht hast, zu faken.
Stimmt, ja.
Deswegen ist das noch ein heiß diskutiertes Thema,
aber bei Git-Projekten oder bei Code-Projekten
ist es ja eigentlich Wurst, weil du
pushst halt dann ein Git-Projekt
mit einer History von 20 Jahren, wenn du willst.
Also dadurch, dass Git an sich schon federated oder distributed ist,
bietet es sich eigentlich ziemlich gut an.
Also was bietet jetzt sowas wie GitHub, GitLab oder 4Geo an,
was nicht schon ein Feature von Git ist?
Gut, es gibt jetzt Git-Hosting.
Zum Beispiel die Verknüpfung von Issues und so weiter.
Es gibt Issues. Issues sind spannend, weil Issues haben Identifikatoren.
Also auf GitHub habe ich ein Issue Nummer 42.
oder ein Pull Request Nummer 43,
der fixes Issue 42
im Text stehen hat.
Und ist das bei 4Geo so,
dass die,
wir hatten das neulich erst besprochen,
nicht auf Band, aber dass sich GitHub eingetreten hat,
dass die IDs von Pull Requests
und Issues quasi
im selben Namespace liegen.
Wenn ich ein Issue aufmache,
dann ist das erste Issue Nummer 1
aufmachen, dann ist der nächste Pull Request,
der allererste Pull Request Nummer 2.
Das ist doof.
Und sind jetzt andere Plattformen wie
Forgeo gezwungen,
ein ähnliches Pattern nachzupontimentieren?
Müssen die sich anfühlen wie GitHub
oder machen die das einfach nicht?
Also du kannst auch auf
gt4geo
mit fixes
Hashtag so und so
Issues schließen.
Ich nehme mal
ganz stark an, dass das...
Wie sieht denn so ein Issue in so einem Forgeo aus?
Genauso wie in Gitti.
Habe ich leider nie benutzt. Wie sieht das aus?
Ich sagst du den GitHub.
Ah ja. Also du hast
Slash Issues Slash 5. Ja, ich muss mal
gucken, ob ich jetzt auf meinem privaten überhaupt irgendwelche
Issues habe.
Aber die
Links sind schon mal eindeutig
für Issues und Pools, wenn das deine Frage ist.
Du kannst ja mal auf meinem CodeWork
Repo mal ein Issue aufmachen.
No Code, weil ich gerade nicht in der Lage
war zu pushen. So, ich gehe mal hier auf ein
anderes vor Geo, wo ich
ein paar
habe.
das sieht hier wirklich aus wie GitHub.
Mal im Ernst.
Und genau.
Das sieht ja eins zu eins aus wie GitHub.
Nein, nicht ganz.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall ähnlich.
Aber die Verwechslungsgefahr ist schon
gefährlich.
Was suchen und du hast halt auch
Organisationen.
Ich habe ein Issue.
Aber ja, die groben
Strukturen sind auf jeden Fall
die gleichen. Es gibt Issues,
Pull Request.
Naja, eben, man soll ja auch das Gleiche damit machen.
Eben, eben.
Du willst ja, dass du Repos danken hast.
Ich meine, GitHub hat sich ja diese, ich nenne es mal,
Domain Knowledge ja nicht aus dem Arsch gezogen.
Die haben das ja auch erarbeitet über die Jahrzehnte.
Es ist ja auch nicht die Erfindung von GitHub,
sondern es ist quasi die Konvention der Community.
Genau.
Ich meine, genauso wie Retweets auf Twitter von der Community erfunden wurden,
haben Leute das so lange gemacht, bis Twitter das als Feature eingebaut hat.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich bei Mastodon auch ein Feature?
oder ist das kein Feature?
Quoten.
Quoten wird aktuell sehr viel
benutzt von Leuten, aber es ist noch kein Feature der
Plattform. Ich fände es geil, wenn es ein Feature der Plattform ist.
Manche Clients rendern das genauso, wie es auf Twitter
ist, aber du kriegst ja diesen
Ja, nee, da fehlt noch was.
Weil Ivory bietet
das jetzt als Feature an.
Das meine ich, genau. Das ist aber quasi einfach
bloß, ich mache einen eigenen
Post, der verlinkt
aber dann den alten
Genau, aber das Problem ist,
Er weiß ja nicht, dass er gequoted wurde.
Genau, dieses Sub-Tweet,
wenn du halt über jemanden
rantest, ohne die Person zu notifien.
Das ist halt gleichzeitig
ein Feature, was für öffentliche Communities sehr gerne
genutzt wird, aber ich finde es scheiße, dass man das nicht mitbekommt.
Also, dass man die Unterhaltung
personuell verpasst, weil nur weil jemand quasi
boosten will mit Kommentar dazu,
das Feature fehlt halt.
Auf Must-Done.
Ist es jetzt ein Feature, dass man das nicht mitbekommt, dass man
gequotet wird? Also, ich finde, es sollte beides geben.
Ich will boosten mit Kommentar
Aber ich will auch etwas verlinken und nur darüber reden,
ohne die Person zuzuspannen.
Aber ist nicht dieses Menschen-Ding einfach nur,
dass du eine URL zu einer Internetseite,
die möglicherweise ein Fedi-Post ist, in den Post reintust
und dann rendert der Kleine dir da halt eine Vorschau-Bildung.
Das ist ja völlig egal, ob das jetzt irgendwie ein Blog-Post oder was weiß ich ist
oder halt ein Tool von irgendjemandem.
Dafür bereits ein Konzept und das gab es
schon bei WordPress.
Und das waren diese
Tracking-Links. Oh, Backlinks.
Backlinks, genau. Du kannst was referenzieren
und einen Link dazu reintun
und dieser Link...
Das war witzigerweise letztens auch bei LML.
Trackback hieß das.
Beziehungsweise gab es dann noch irgendwie so eine...
Du hast dann einen RPC-Post an diese URL.
Das war so ein XML-RPC-Konzept.
Naja, aber so ungefähr
oder was heißt so ungefähr?
Activity-Pub ist ja das Protokoll, was
diesen ganzen Konzepten dann aufgebaut hat
und ich denke, wenn du das wollen würdest...
Für zurück bis zu WordPress?
Naja, also nicht direkt, aber
also das, was halt mit diesem Trackback-Pingback
und
dem darauf aufbauenden Konzept,
wie hieß das nochmal? Irgendwas mit
PubSubHubbub oder so, war auch nochmal
so ein Protokoll und aus dem
ist dann ActivityPub hervorgegangen, wenn ich
da jetzt so richtig informiert bin, aber ihr erzählt ja hier auch
mal. Ich verlinke mal
die Trackpack Wikipedia Page mit
in den Shownotes und die haben den witzigen
Name
mitgecoint für
Spam über diese
Pingbacks.
Schön.
Jedenfalls würde ich sagen, wenn man wollen würde,
dass man halt eben
einen Link
an der
auf der Instanz
oder an dem User Account über
den, also das verlinkt wurde,
dem Bescheid sagen wollen würde,
würde das Protokoll das auch anbieten, denke ich,
weil das macht es ja, wenn man eine Ad-Mension macht auch
und das muss ja auch nur gecodet werden,
dass es dann halt eben so ein Ping hinsetzt
und dann müsste wahrscheinlich die sendende Instanz erkennen,
dass es sich hier um einen Link zu einer weiteren Fedi-Instanz handelt
und dann eben dort den entsprechenden Ping hinsenden
oder das macht es sowieso und lässt die Empfang der Instanz entscheiden
ob sie jetzt mit dem
Ping irgendwas anfangen. Ich sehe, wir müssen alle mal das Activity
Pub, die Spec lesen.
Ja, ich denke auch. Ich bin bei der Aussage gerade
sehr zitierbar mit, das muss ja einfach nur
gecodet werden. Na klar.
Das betrifft so viele Probleme.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie, man müsste
mal was implementieren. Müsste man einfach mal machen.
Ja. Einfach mal sich
hinsetzen und machen.
Nee, aber ich meine, um
mal zurückzukommen,
vor Geo klingt natürlich unglaublich cool.
Ich finde es cool, dass Gitti so weiterentwickelt wird und da sehr aktiv auch genutzt wird. Ich finde es schön, dass es Plattformen gibt wie Codework, die auch explizit den Wunsch haben, ein Ort zu sein für offene Dinge und nicht nur für ein spezifisches Projekt, weil auch das muss es geben.
Ich finde es ein bisschen schwierig, wo sich das hin entwickeln muss, zwangsläufig in Zukunft. Was passiert, wenn da mal jemand einen DMC-Abequest hinschickt? Das wird sicher lustig.
das erste. Das war jetzt eigentlich das Takeaway
bei Mastodon, was das angeht.
Es gibt ja, das ist
ein super weiterer Punkt
für was, was für
Zentralisierung steht von solchen
Instanzen.
Bei GitHub
gab es diese ICE-Geschichte
und sie sind zu Recht kritisiert
worden dafür, dass sie den Code von
ICE hosten.
Nennt, dass sie mit ICE zusammenarbeiten.
Achso, die Geschichte habe ich noch gar nicht,
ich muss sagen, ich habe mich auch gar nicht so richtig reingelesen,
Aber es geht darum, dass sie eine Instanz sind,
die für Sachen theoretisch zur Rechenschaft gezogen werden kann.
GitHub, nee, Quatsch.
Twitter hatte vor der Musk-Übernahme eine Riesenabteilung,
die Content-Moderation gemacht hat.
Und die haben Ressourcen von so einer Firma darauf werfen können,
sowas wie dokumentierten Kinder-Missbrauch von der Plattform fernzuhalten.
So was stemmt so eine kleine Mastodon-Instanz nicht,
wenn ich einen Mastodon-Instanz betreibe
und das aus gutem Willen tue
und das da plötzlich von diesen Kreisen benutzt wird,
um solchen Content auszutauschen.
Was mache ich dann?
Also ich denke, da kannst du gerne für die nächste Folge
Akronymisierbar mal üg-üg einladen.
Die kann dir einen langen Vortrag halten
über Content-Moderation im Fediverse.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall kein triviales Problem, aber das ist ja eigentlich jetzt nicht nur ein Problem, was jetzt ein föderiertes Forgeo hätte oder ein föderiertes Mastodon, sondern was allgemein ein, ich bleib mal bei dem Wort Problem, im Internet ist, wenn es dezentral ist.
natürlich wenn du jetzt
irgendeinen Mist hostest, dann kann
die Polizei vor deiner Tür stehen und dir
deinen Server mitnehmen, aber wenn sie das
gemacht haben, ist halt jetzt nur dein Server weg und
nicht alle anderen gleich mit und das ist ja der
Vorteil
wenn links unten mal wieder
genau, also das ganze
Internet ist nicht kaputt gegangen, weil
links unten
bei AWS wieder
ein Server abbrennen
man kann mittlerweile auch argumentieren
gut, okay, wir brauchen
wahrscheinlich im Jahr 2024 nicht mehr
die Ressourcen einer großen
Corporation,
um solche Content-Moderation zu machen,
weil potenziell, und das ist
ein gutes Feature von AI,
sowas wie Hass-Postings
oder wahrscheinlich sogar
solche Missbrauchskontents auch von
AIs, die man potenziell auch
lokal hosten kann, einigermaßen
erkannt werden kann. Jetzt begeke ich mich so ein bisschen in heißes Wasser,
weil ich mich mit dem Thema gar nicht aufs Neuesen habe.
Das ist aber super spannend, weil
Der Typ, der Pixel-Fed baut, diesen Instagram-Pediverse-Klon, Dan Sub, der hat da letztens richtig viel Mühe reingesteckt, gerade was wirklich so AI-Spam-Erkennung mit angeht.
Ich weiß nicht, was genau die AI-Base davon ist, also auf welcher Ebene das eben basiert, aber da steckt erstaunlich viel Mühe und cooles Engineering mit drin.
da steckt da schaulich viel Mühe und cooles Engineering mit drin,
da ein starkes Feature mit auf die Beine zu stellen.
Das ist natürlich, also
er baut ja gleich einen komplett
neuen Filiber Service, ich weiß nicht, was der
korrekte Begriff hier wäre, und gleichzeitig
betreibt er auch mit den größten Server davon.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie groß Pixelfat.social ist.
Aber Pixelfat.social ist auch nur
ActivityPub, oder? Es ist ActivityPub,
aber es ist eine komplett eigene Anwendung.
Es ist Pixelfat. Es ist kein Masto-Server
oder so, es ist Pixelfat. Man kann aber
mit einem Masto-Account, einem Pixelfat-Account
folgen und sieht auch alle Bilder und man kann
da antworten. Es spricht die Kibitipop, ja.
Also das ist dann quasi, wo
Mastodon selber
den Twitter-Use-Case erfüllt,
so pixelfettig, ich hab's schon mal gehört.
Das sieht auch
eigentlich fast genauso aus, wenn man
das irgendwie sich einnimmt. Es ist genau das der Gedanke
dahinter, ja.
Ja, und da wäre es jetzt mal spannend,
so, wir haben
in diesem Podcast noch nicht über AI geredet und werden
es jetzt auch in dieser Folge nicht tun, aber mich würde
tatsächlich dann das Thema, also
Open Source LLM Applications
zur Erkennung von Hate Speech
oder sowas, aber faszinierend.
Ganz kurz Live-Feedback von mir selber
an mich selber. Ich will
den Pixel-Fed-Blog-Post mit verlinken
dazu und es ist gar nicht mal so sehr AI.
Es ist ein Base-Filter,
also quasi da, wo wir Spam-Filter
angefangen haben,
aber auch trainiert auf explizit
passenden Spam-Daten, die
dafür abbildbar sind. Ich verlinke die Post aber auch
mit. Gut, genau. Also wir wollen jetzt dieses,
wir lassen dieses Thema mal aus,
wir könnten da jetzt viel spekulieren, aber wir wissen einfach
überhaupt nichts darüber. Das wäre mal spannend,
mit jemandem zu reden, der sich mit diesem
Thema tatsächlich mal auseinandersetzen muss.
Zum Beispiel Betreiber von
Mastodon-Instanzen.
Was die da drauf schmeißen, die haben wahrscheinlich schon mal
reingeschaut, was man so aus
Hugging-Face für
speziell abgeleitete LLMs
nehmen kann.
Ich meine, gerade das bringt halt diverse
neue Probleme wieder mit sich.
Hugging-Face ist doch auch wieder so ein zentralisierter
so wie GitHub und
Facebook und so weiter.
Wer das Hugging-Face ist,
ist das Facebook für AI
Testing.
Und da
wird es hoffentlich vielleicht auch irgendwann mal
eine dezentrale Sache geben, wo man die
M's föderiert
verwenden kann.
AI wird auch nochmal, was so
Open Sourcing und Federation angeht,
ein richtig bitteres Thema werden, weil du kannst
es eigentlich
also neue
neue LNMs kannst du eigentlich
nur auf massiver Infrastruktur mit
viel Geld und Energie antrainieren.
Und weil oftmals am Ende dann
Binär-Blobs auseinander
verteilt werden, was dann deine trainierten
Models sind. Was aber, ich weiß nicht,
ob ich es damit zu früh anschneide.
Wir haben vorhin schon mal ganz kurz über Binärgeräte und ich habe mir auf die Zunge
gebissen, aber vielleicht können wir langsam...
Ich wollte jetzt keine Überleitung nutzen, nämlich zu einem anderen
Thema, wo es um Binär-Blobs geht.
Nämlich eine Sache, die wir auf jeden Fall News-mäßig
ansprechen müssen, ist diese ganze XC-Thematik.
Habt ihr alle eure Linux-Kisten geupdatet?
Oder nicht geupdatet?
Ich benutze Debian Stable auf den Kisten,
auf denen ich Debian benutze
und habe deswegen gelesen,
dass das für mich nicht relevant ist.
Aber auch nur, weil wir auf den anderen Debian Testing
das eben ordentlich behandelt haben.
Der Typ, der es gefunden hat,
hat Debian Testing verwendet.
I'm using Arch, by the way.
Und mir ist das auch als erstes...
Also wir reden über das XZ-Exploit.
Das Schöne ist, wir haben eine relativ kleine Hörerschaft,
die wir zum größten Teil auch persönlich kennen.
Also ich gehe immer fest davon aus,
dass die Leute das jetzt hier hören.
Wir sollten es trotzdem mal kurz ansprechen, was passiert ist.
Was mir passiert ist, ist, dass ich von über den Arch Linux Mastodon Account
davon das erste Mal gehört habe.
Nice.
Ich benutze diesen Arch Linux Rechner aber nicht hinreichend häufig genug,
dass ich zu dem Zeitpunkt bereits das Update gemacht habe.
Aber normalerweise ist ja ein Arch-Entwickler,
ein Arch-Nutzer hat das quasi schon so obsessively in den Fingern.
Du loggst dich ein und das Erste, was du machst,
ist ein Pac-Man-Update.
Das ist einfach ein Cronjob on System Start.
In meinem Setup...
Ein Rechner, der am Internet hängt, ist ja eigentlich meistens an.
Stimmt, einfach ein Cronjob geht alle fünf Minuten,
wenn ein Update installiert.
Naja, das heißt
Unattended Upgrades.
Die Kernel
Update ich bei mir eigentlich nur
On-Demand. Meistens mache ich
Pac-Man-Update, also
S-Y-Y-Ignore-Linux.
Aber lass uns jetzt nicht drüber reden.
Was ist denn passiert?
Es gab einen Angriff auf
ein Open-Source-Projekt.
Und zwar, wir verlinken auch diesen
einen bekannten XKCD hier drunter,
von wegen, wie Software-Infrastruktur
Du hast komplexen Stack, es liegen diverse Sachen in deinen Dependencies, diverse Libraries, auf denen du Sachen aufbaust und irgendwo ganz weit unten im Stack ist eine Stütze, die alles irgendwie am Leben hält, das Maintain von einer Person sonst wo und diese eine Person macht einen sehr undankbaren Job, weil niemand mitkriegt, dass diese Person diese kritische Infrastruktur maintained, aber würde sie es nicht tun, würden sehr viele Dinge kaputt gehen.
Wir haben das damals schon mit LeftPad uns darauf bezogen.
Sie akonomisieren aber einstellig wahrscheinlich.
Sonst von der Vergangenheit.
Und das war jetzt um LibLCMA, von dem niemand wusste, dass es Teil von XZ ist.
Genau.
Und das ist...
Ich wollte eine Silicon Valley-Referenz machen.
Das geht um Compression.
Um XZ.
Outside in.
Middle out.
Middle out ist das.
Genau.
Und dieses Projekt steckt in diversen Sachen mit drin.
und ist dadurch, dass es halt relativ tief im Stack hängt, quasi irgendwo mit in jeder Distro vorhanden,
wenn du irgendwelche aktuellen Betriebssysteme nutzt.
Und da gab es eben einen sehr spannend gecrafteten Exploit.
Kein Exploit ist softwareseitig, sondern mehr so, es hat sich jemand oder eine potenzielle Gruppe von Menschen
oder irgendein größerer Actor, mindestens eine Person versucht, als Maintainer in dieses Projekt einzuschleusen.
Und das Interessante an dieser ganzen Thematik ist halt vor allem, dass es sehr viel auch auf Social Engineering Basis passiert ist, wie es überhaupt dazu kam, dass diese Leute Rechte dazu bekommen haben, dort Sachen zu maintainen. Und zwar wurde das Projekt, um das es ging, von einer Person, von Lasse Collin, maintained, schon seit einer ganzen Leile. Und diese eine Person hatte Probleme, damit überhaupt zurande zu kommen. Und das Projekt wirkte relativ unmaintained.
Einzel und allein daraus, also ich glaube, es stand sogar beim Projekt mit dabei, Sicherheitsupdates wird es geben, aber vielmehr nicht, vor allem keine neuen Feature-Entwicklungen, weil es einfach nicht stemmbar ist vom Aufwand, der da gemacht werden muss. Und dann gab es wohl Issues, die aufgemacht wurden von einer Person, ich habe den Namen jetzt nicht vor mir hier, wo relativ kritisch gefragt wurde, auch sehr vorwurfsvoll, wie es denn sein kann, dass das nicht maintained wird.
kümmer dich mal hier, das wird aktiv benutzt.
Es kann nicht sein, dass du Teil von sonst wo,
die weiß nicht, ob es Debian explizit mit war, bist,
wo das mit reinfließt, aber das wird hier nicht aktiv benutzt.
Das geht ja gar nicht.
Und es wurde sehr, sehr wirklich kritisch,
wirklich sehr Schuldgefühl verursachend, das mit angesprochen.
Und es gab eine andere Person mit dem Namen Jia Tan,
die sich zu dem Zeitpunkt schon versucht hatte, mit einzubringen
und da diverse Patches mit reingelandet hat.
Aber wurde von dieser anderen Person auch mit angesprochen,
mit, lass doch die Person da mit reinziehen,
die ja anscheinend Kappas hat,
damit zu unterstützen. Das bietet
sich doch prima an und dann kann man da
das abwälzen. Also es wurde sehr viel
Lasse-Colin in die Richtung gepusht,
Gia Tan die
Hand mit auszureichen und Gia Tan
die Rechte zu geben, damit Code rein zu
pushen. Und so ist es auch immer mehr dann passiert.
Und das war, also
ich würde fast vermuten, der
Verschwörungstheoretiker in mir, dass das eine und die selbe Person war.
In der Hoffnung, dass es
wirklich nur eine Person war
und kein Nation-Level-Actor, der dahinter steckt.
Aber es wurde auf jeden Fall sehr spannend.
Ich halte es gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich,
dass das einfach Pseudonyme sind.
Das ist safe.
Du kannst dir, wenn du so eine Attacke fahren willst,
schaust du dir eine Weile an,
was sind Dependencies, die überall mit einfließen.
Absolut.
Dann schaust du dich ein bisschen um,
dann wirst du aus, von was für Leuten werden die maintained.
Und dann ist so ein XZ-Projekt,
was in, ich meine, der Angriff war dann,
basierend auf der Tatsache, dass es in
Open-SSH-Demon
reingelenkt wird. Ich will nicht
zu viel vorausnehmen, aber
das ist einfach eine Goldmine
gewesen, was das angeht. Das ist eine
Dependency, die in allen Systemen
an einer kritischen Stelle
mitverwendet wird
und von einer einzelnen Person
oder beziehungsweise eigentlich ist ja
das Problem nicht nur, dass diese eine Person das alleine
mentiert. Ist ja okay, wenn die sagt,
ich
mache da jetzt nicht mehr viel dran, man muss ja
ich implementiere halt diese SIPs,
diese Compression-Spec, was soll man
dann noch machen, aber
es hätte ja auch zum Beispiel der Zugang
dieser einen Person zu dem Repo
anderweitig bereits kompromittiert worden sein.
Das ist ein Problem.
Aber, sorry,
weiter, wo war das Problem?
Nee, ich meine, prinzipiell, also mir ging es vor allem
um den Voraspekt hier, also wie es
überhaupt dazu kam, dass diese Person da
irgendwie Rechte dazu bekommen hat, nämlich durch diesen
spannenden Aspekt des Social Engineering,
was wir so öffentlich in der Form bisher noch nicht bekannt gesehen haben.
Zumindest nicht so, dass es aufgefallen wäre.
Und das ist jetzt ein bisschen der beängstigende Teil davon.
Aber wie du schon richtig sagst, es geht natürlich dann weiter in die Richtung,
dass das Ganze irgendwie bei SSH mit drin hängt.
Und ich glaube, der Exploit, die genauen Details sind gar nicht mehr im Kopf,
läuft darauf hinaus, dass letztendlich es geht darum, gegen Private Keys einzuschleusen,
die in Open SSH gleich mit ausgeliefert werden,
in irgendwelchen Binary Blobs, die über Testdaten mit reingeflossen sind in XZ.
Und das wäre jetzt letztendlich der Tag Vector am Ende gewesen.
Wenn es wirklich nicht aufgefallen wäre
und diese Vulnerable Binary Blobs irgendwie mit ausgeliefert wären,
dass auch sehr spannend sind,
dass da irgendwelche Binär Blobs überhaupt nicht rumliegen,
dann hätte Person oder Actor oder wer auch immer hier dahinter steckt,
letztendlich SSH-Zugang zu jedem öffentlich zugänglichen System gehabt.
Was scary as fuck ist.
Also das ist so, das geht weit über das hinaus,
was man erwarten würde, wie einfach das wäre,
Zugriff auf jedes System zu haben.
Und das war auch das Witzige, wie es jetzt endlich aufgefallen ist,
weil es eben einen Entwickler bei Microsoft gab,
Andres Freund heißt die Person,
das ist wirklich ein echter Kumpel vom Namen her,
die anscheinend gemerkt hat,
beim Benchmarken von SSH irgendwie,
dass das System sich plötzlich ein bisschen anders verhält
und eine halbe Sekunde länger braucht.
Was er fucking staunlich ist für eine Firma wie Microsoft,
Ich habe da so ein schönes Meme gerade vor mir.
Hier ist so ein Simpsons-Meme mit Blind Bart.
Microsoft Software Engineer
When Teams takes five minutes to start
and freezes mit Call.
Wie, was?
Nee, alles as intended.
Microsoft Software Engineer
When SSH Login starts taking 0.5 seconds.
Da müssen wir genauer hinschauen.
Also das ist echt krass.
Aber klar, bei Microsoft arbeiten natürlich auch
unglaublich viele extrem fähige Menschen.
Und es ist fantastisch, dass das aufgefallen ist.
Und deswegen wurde da halt ein bisschen mal
mehr draufgeschaut mit Laser-Eyes.
und wirklich ein Audit gefahren an der Stelle
und somit ist das hier aufgefallen,
dieses horrende Konstrukt, was da mit
dahinter hängt. Und das ist wirklich
richtig, richtig insane.
Das ist jetzt erst vor ein paar Tagen passiert.
Vor einer Woche.
Vor einer Woche, vor anderthalb Wochen irgendwie sowas.
Das war genau zu Oster.
Ja, stimmt, genau. Und fantastisches Timing auch.
Das sind irgendwie so Feiertage.
Und ich glaube, Lasse Colin hatte auch dann irgendwie
keine Kapazitäten wirklich direkt
zu replyen, aber hat ein fantastisch,
wirklich richtig gut aufgearbeitet,
auf der eigenen Homepage auch mit, was ist gerade der Stand der Dinge,
das hier ist passiert
und hat da auch das ganze Up-to-Date gehalten,
also krass, auch gerade über Feiertage sowas
mit zu stemmen, was sicherlich nicht
das Einfachste war,
aber also das ist wirklich eine,
diese Timeline liest sich wie
ein Filmskript, also da kannst du
wirklich einen neuen Film-Hackers drüber drehen,
was hier passiert. Ich freue mich schon auf die,
also das ist ein bisschen weird jetzt,
weil wir drüber reden und die anderen
haben es noch nicht, aber ich freue mich ehrlich gesagt schon
ein bisschen auf die Logbuch-Netzepolitik.
Da habe ich auch schon mal nachgedacht.
Eigentlich wollte ich die Logbuch-Netzepolitik-Folge dazu hören,
um mir das mal genau erklären zu lassen.
Jetzt hat Kilian das gemacht. Vielen Dank.
Ich freue mich auch sehr auf die Logbuch-Netzepolitik.
Ob wir noch nicht eingegangen sind,
aber es gibt auch schon Berichte.
Ich habe ein gutes YouTube-Video darüber gesehen,
wie der Code eingeschleust wurde.
Das war ja wirklich von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge
über Binary Blobs, die sich als Testdaten ausgegeben haben.
dann hat die Person Benchmarks eingecheckt
und modifizierte ZIP-Files, waren das ZIP-Files oder GZIP-Files,
oder Testdaten eingecheckt, um zu verifizieren,
dass die Daten, diese Benchmarks funktionieren.
Und da war Payload eingeschleust,
der dann im Build-Skript in die Binary reingepatcht wurde.
Aber wichtig zu erwähnen auch,
das ist nicht ein Commit, der hier passiert ist.
Also es fängt schon Mitte 2023 an, wo hier Changes gemacht wurden,
die bestimmte Fuzzing-Sachen, glaube ich, ausgeschaltet haben,
damit diese Changes später maskiert werden und einfach nicht auffallen direkt.
Und das ist halt so absurd, was da, also so wie du es schon sagst,
dass das binäre Testdaten sind, das ist halt nicht so ein,
da hat jemand aus der Hüfte geschossen und versucht, einen Exploiter einzuschleusen.
Das ist ein Prozess, der lange entwickelt wurde,
wo wirklich richtig Gehirnschmalz reingeflossen ist,
wie man das am besten auffährt.
Insane.
Ich stelle die These in den Raum,
ich halte es für nicht
unwahrscheinlich, überhaupt nicht,
dass das so von langer Hand, wie das
geplant wurde, dass das tatsächlich
ein Nation-State-Angriff
war. Und der spannende
Ansatz
ist jetzt, in anderen Projekten, in anderen
Open-Source-Projekten nach ähnlichen Patterns
zu suchen, wo Leute...
Das ist halt echt nicht einfach.
Es gibt ja immer mal wieder Geschichten, gab es auch auf NPM,
wo Leute sich... Was war das? Es war nicht
Left-Pad, aber es war auch ein anderes
Projekt, wo sich Leute als
hier, ey, ich übernehme mal
dein NPM-Projekt, du machst ja nichts mehr,
wenn du willst, kann ich Ownership übernehmen.
Oder du kaufst es sogar und bietest ihm
Geld und plötzlich gehöriert sie, oder dass Leute
deine Dependents Bescheid wissen. Und ich meine, was dann
passiert ist, was in den Fällen
dann passiert ist, ich habe die Beispiele gerade nicht namentlich
parat, aber dann haben die Leute halt
Kryptominer eingecheckt. Und wir hatten dann plötzlich
Warbex bei uns in der CI, weil unsere CI auf Arbeit
da irgendwie beim Testen
unseres Codes dann irgendwie angefangen hat,
sehr viel CPU zu verbrauchen.
Das ist halt schon...
Sowas kann man da zurückrollen.
Umfassendes Monitoring ist auf jeden Fall wichtig an der Stelle.
Man sieht halt, die eine Person hat das gemacht
und hier hat man
jetzt ein
Pseudonym
mit einem, ich glaube, chinesischen Namen.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das wirklich...
Also,
ob das dann jetzt darauf deutet, dass es
China war oder
jemand einfach China...
Es ist
ein bisschen witzig, muss ich sagen.
Und also
vor allen Dingen, wenn man jetzt irgendwie ankommt, ja, hier waren
irgendwelche chinesischen Schriftzeichen,
manchmal sind es auch russische Schriftzeichen,
denn, also ich würde mir sagen, wenn ich so einen
Angriff machen würde, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall auch russische
Schriftzeichen da reinmachen, so, und einfach nur damit
das halt...
Na klar, aber ich meine, da bin ich jetzt auch
nicht der Einzige, der auf die Idee kommen würde, von daher
würde ich da auf jeden Fall sehr vorsichtig
sein, da jetzt schon mal irgendwelche Ansagen zu machen.
irgendwie den Leuten
eine Seite in die Augen zu streuen, da irgendwie Probleme
irgendwo anders zu schicken. Was ich immer spannend finde,
ich weiß nicht, ob es stimmt, ist, dass die, dass sich so
nicht Kryptomainer,
sondern, wie heißen diese
Verschlüsselungstrojaner?
Ach, Ransomware. Ja, das ist so Ransomware,
als allerallererstes checkt, ob der Computer,
auf dem sie laufen, irgendwie eine kyrillische
Dastatur angeschlossen hat und dann sich sofort
deaktiviert, weil sie natürlich nicht irgendwie aus Versehen
auf irgendwelchen Ministeriencomputern
in Russland laufen wollen,
weil das ja dann nämlich mit den Leuten in ihrem eigenen
Probleme kriegen. Das finde ich schon sehr lustig.
Witzig, woran man sowas
anders machen. Aber das diverse
Software, wir haben ja schon länger, seit
Jahrzehnten versucht, zu erkennen, ob es eine
VM ist, weil sie ja nicht von
Security-Vorschriften analysiert werden wollen.
Und sie versuchen, restlos zu entfernen, wenn sie
merken, oh shit, ist eine VM.
Oder es ist halt
ein russischer
Staatsbürger, der ja irgendwie laut Gesetz
nicht gehackt werden darf und
alle anderen schon. Da gibt es doch, ich glaube,
inzwischen zwei Talks von Linus Neumann,
vom Camp und vom Kongress, wo er darüber berichtet,
wie er einen Trojaner
oder irgendeine Ransomware da hatte
und
ein Kumpel dabei, der Russisch konnte
und dann haben die im Chat plötzlich Russisch miteinander gesprochen
und dann sollte der noch irgendeine ID hinhalten
und dann haben sie irgendeine ID da hingebastelt
und in die Kamera gehalten
und dann hat er das kostenlos wieder aufgesperrt bekommen.
Musste auch irgendwie in die Show Notes tun.
Das sind, glaube ich, zwei Talks.
Ich erinnere mich an den Talk, ja.
Und ja, also das Gesetz gibt es da irgendwie offensichtlich auch, aber das heißt jetzt noch lange nicht, dass immer wenn irgendwie irgendwas nach Russischem aussieht, dann auch wirklich da der Ursprung ist.
Also ich würde auch als NSA irgendwas Russisches irgendwo reinschreiben, einfach nur damit es nicht so aussieht.
Da kann man relativ schnell Blameshifting betreiben.
Aber dass
dieses Problem,
dass kritische Infrastruktur
auf sowas fußt
und das dann
angegriffen werden kann, ist natürlich
überall vorhanden.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie man damit umgehen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man mit Federation damit umgehen kann.
Ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel
von Armin Ronacher
einen Blogpost, den schmeiße ich einfach mal mit
zur Referenz
in die
Show Notes mit rein, der heißt
On TechTab, my Rust Library
is now a CDO.
Ich müsste den Begriff erstmal nachgucken, die Referenz
geht irgendwie auf ein
A CDO is a financial instrument
that became very infamous during the financial crisis
of 2007 and an entertaining
explanation can be found in
the big short. Ich kenne es nur als
Chief Design Officer, was sonst?
Anyway, es geht in dem
Fall auch um Libraries,
die kritische
Infrastruktur sind.
weil sie überall drin sind.
Zum Beispiel, wir haben vor zwei Folgen darüber geredet,
fast jede Library von David Tolney im Rust-Ökosystem.
Der Typ, der Serde gebaut hat.
Also wenn du auf Crates.io gehst
und da die most popular Crates anschaust,
sind fast alle von dem.
Und der hatte im Zuge von...
Es gibt diesen einen YAML-Parser,
der fast überall drin ist,
der einfach seit
vier Jahren nicht mehr maintained wird.
Und ich sehe, ich folge dem auch, weil ich auch schon
Pre-Requests aufgemacht habe. Und ich sehe,
Leute machen Pre-Requests auf, machen Issues auf und es
passiert einfach immer nichts.
Und so, trotzdem ist der halt noch überall drin,
weil sich keiner, du hättest ja das Ding
noch vonken können, ja, aber keiner will sich
diesen Schuh anziehen. Und mittlerweile
hat es tatsächlich jemand gemacht
und gesagt, fuck it,
I do it myself.
Und jetzt gibt es, also der
Name von der Libber vorher schon scheiße, die hieß einfach
YAML-RUST
und jetzt gibt es YAML-RUST 2
und wenn du auf dem alten
Ding ein Issue aufmachst oder auch nur auf eins
kommentierst, trust me, I know, dann
bleibt der Typ direkt unten drunter,
wollt ihr das Issue vielleicht auf dem neuen Repo aufmachen?
Ich maintain jetzt einen Frog, der heißt YAML-RUST 2.
Nehmt doch den überall.
Jetzt beobachte ich so ein bisschen über die nächsten Monate,
ob die Proliferation dieser beiden
Lips sich gegeneinander verhält, ob wirklich viele
migrieren von dem einen zu dem anderen.
Eigentlich muss man es unbedingt tun.
Ja, das ist echt
vergammelte Software ist nicht.
Ich meine, bei GNU-Software
oder bei Linux-Software
ist es so, die haben sich halt irgendwann gedacht,
fuck it, I do it myself
und wollten halt von allem,
was sie damals auf Unix schon verwendet haben,
einfach eine GNU-Variante haben und haben
sich hingesetzt und Richard Storm
hat einfach alles nochmal selber geschrieben.
Ich sehe nicht zuletzt Valky, der Redis-Fork
bei der Linux-Foundation.
Ich habe gestern das gelesen
und ich suchte es nochmal raus
auf Hacker News, die
Originalerfinder von M4, diesem
Autotools-Bildsystem.
Ich habe es nie benutzt, ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Es ist hässlich.
Er hat gesagt, ich hatte das
damals mal für Unix gebaut irgendwann
und ich fand es selber scheiße und wollte was anderes machen, aber
Stormwind wollte, dass ich es nochmal neu für GNU baue,
damit es
eine GNU-Lizenz vorliegt,
eine GPL vorliegt und jetzt benutzen
es immer noch Leute und ich wollte es damals schon ersetzen
durch was Neues, aber wir müssen es nochmal neu machen.
Ich fand es sehr lustig.
Aber um nochmal einen Raken zurück zur XC zu schlagen,
ich weiß nicht, ob du das vorhin gesagt hast oder nicht,
aber eins der
scariesten Teile daran ist ja,
das ist jetzt der eine Fall, wo wir es mitbekommen haben.
Genau. Und jetzt ist der spannende Teil
irgendwie nach ähnlichen Patterns in anderen
Projekten zu suchen. Ob, wo es schon
längst passiert ist. Und potenziell sind wir ja
alle betroffen und da liegen irgendwelche Leute,
da haben Ruze zugehörigen an unsere Maschinen und es
weiß man nicht. Also ich warte jetzt
wirklich auf den Fallout, der da
lauten wird, okay, wir haben jetzt, nachdem das
passiert ist, nach dem Pattern gesucht und wir haben
hier, hier und dort was.
Da schmeißen sich hoffentlich auch gerade etliche Security-Forscher
und Forscherinnen drauf, weil einfach auch
mega, also wäre fantastisch noch
sowas zu finden. Nicht fantastisch, was da ist,
aber das zu finden, das muss auch geil sein.
Es ist
super dankbar und ich glaube, der Typ,
der das gefunden hat, der hat auch
Forever Credit im
Internet und wird sich auf die Schulter
klopfen lassen. Also wenn ich den treffe, gebe ich dem auch ein Bier.
Ist halt ein echt guter Freund, der andere
ist Freund. Genau, aber
Kommt der aus Deutschland?
Beim Vornamen würde ich nicht davon ausgehen,
aber ich weiß es nicht.
Anyway,
es ist schon ein Riesenglück,
dass das gefunden wurde trotzdem.
Sein gesamter Wikipedia-Artikel
bezieht sich auf XC.
Oh Mann.
Ja, Microsoft Employee
und PostgreSQL-Developer.
Man of the Year, würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, aber
ich hoffe,
ehrlich gesagt, dass solche Sachen jetzt noch
gefunden werden, weil ich
denke nicht, dass das der erste
Fall ist. Man kann ja mal damit
anfangen, Binary Blobs in
Git-Repos zu suchen, weil ich finde, die haben da eh
nichts dran zu suchen. Ja,
prinzipiell ja, aber dann denke
ich an diesen einen spezifischen Use Case hier,
wo es darum geht,
Compressed Test Assets für deine
Library zu haben und ja, da fließt
halt schon irgendwo. Aber ja, ist halt ein
massives Issue. Da müsst ihr wahrscheinlich eher
im Repo Tooling haben,
was diese Testdaten erzeugen kann.
Aber es ist schon, also
ja, Binärblobs haben prinzipiell
nichts verloren, weil sie halt einfach
als Binärdaten intransparent
sind.
Was ist an Binärdaten intransparent?
Du hast halt diesen Daten angesehen,
du hättest den Daten schon ansehen
können. Da ist irgendwie mehr drin, als hätte drin sein
müssen. Und du möchtest,
wenn du, was weiß ich,
einen Parser baust oder irgendwelche
anderen Sachen, die auf Binärdaten arbeiten, dann hast
du Testdaten.
Ich meine, du kannst natürlich auch wirklich einfach bloß
Ende-zu-Ende-Code-Tests
bauen, die das auf der einen Seite erzeugen und auf der anderen Seite
wieder fressen, aber du kannst mir schon vorstellen,
dass es hier und da echte Use Cases
dafür gibt.
Wir hatten auch darüber geredet, dass
in diesem Serde-Parser plötzlich Binarys
eingecheckt waren, weil der Typ gesagt hat,
das effektivste oder effizienteste ist für
die Compile-Timed, wenn es einfach für jede
Plattform bereits eine Binary gibt.
Jetzt haben wir ein fantastisches Gegenargument dafür.
Auf der anderen Seite
eben. Da ist das Gegenargument, dass es schneller
geht. Genau so was hat ja damals so eine
Riesendiskussion ausgelöst. Also
der Maintainer von Cerde,
was in fast jedem Rust-Projekt
drin ist, hat sich von Version
1.0.68
auf Version
1.0.69
oder noch höher, weiter weg von
1.0, aber es war 1.0. irgendwas,
gedacht, ich finde,
ich check jetzt mal die Binary
Version von dem Makro ein.
Und das ist ja derselbe Typ, der an sich
nicht ganz unumstritten
ist, weil er, glaube ich, immer noch
für Palantir arbeitet.
Ich verlinke hier auch nochmal
das gute alte Trusting Trust Paper.
Und
das ist zumindest ein generelles Problem,
aber wahrscheinlich könnte man diese Sachen finden, wenn man
hingeht und sagt, okay, wenn ich der
Angreifer wäre.
was würde ich machen?
Und da ist halt sowas wie XZ
ein valides,
gutes, naheliegendes
Ziel. Aber es ist halt auch nicht super trivial,
diese Ziele zu identifizieren. Das ist halt richtig
gute, ist das...
Du nimmst dir halt so die verbreitetsten
Systeme und schaust halt
den Stammbaum
jeder einzelnen Zeile Code an und wer das heutzutage
noch mitteilt. Deswegen war das Spannende halt
bei GNU,
da gab es plötzlich von allem einen Fork,
der von diesem GNU-Projekt mit
Maintained wurde und es kam dann plötzlich alles aus einer Hand.
Dieses
wir ziehen uns
unsere Dependencies, wir machen die nicht alle selber,
wir bauen das nicht selber, sondern wir ziehen uns einfach live
upstream aus der Community
alles was wir brauchen
federated
ist geil und
ein Supply Chain Security Nightmare.
Oder du brauchst viel
Caching. Also du hast ja auch
selber irgendwann schon mal erzählt, dass ihr bei euch
auf Arbeit irgendwann angefangen habt
die ganze NPM
Dependency irgendwie lokal zu cachen.
Das ist ein Standard-Pendor. Du hast, wenn du sowas
baust intern, hast du für deine eigene CI
ein
Cache von diesen Public
Info.
Und wenn sich daran dann irgendwann was ändert,
dann müsste da schon wieder irgendein Monitoring
aufleuchten. Zum Beispiel
wenn in diesem Binary
Paket, was halt
irgendwie, ja, wenn du halt irgendwas, was entpacken soll,
testest, dann brauchst du was Gepacktes, um es
testen. Klar, das kann man machen, indem man das erst packt.
So hätte ich das wahrscheinlich auch gemacht.
Oder du nimmst halt irgendein
Binary-Ding, was da drin ist. Und wenn
sich das dann aber irgendwann mal ändert, obwohl du gar nichts
gemacht hast, dann
könnte meiner Meinung nach auch irgendwo
eine Lampe nehmen. Der hat ja tatsächlich was gemacht, wo
er gesagt hat, ich habe jetzt immer weitere Sachen
gebenchmarked und dann irgendwie diese
Testdaten modifiziert.
Die Hand ist wirklich schon clever
da reingesnackt. Ja, na klar.
Gerade so wie du erklärt hast, in dem Zusammenhang mit,
dass jemand überhaupt gar keinen Bock mehr hatte und dann
jemand anders sagt, hey, ich mach's, dann
ja, na klar, dann passieren so eine Sachen schon.
Vor allem nicht nur ein Jahr,
ich mach's, oh ja, nee, wer bist du, sondern
ja, ich mach's und hier sind haufenweise gute Channies
ein halbes Jahr später, oh Gott.
Oh je. Genau, also der erste Teil
war Social Engineering, sich in dieses Projekt
reinzuwanzen. Da war einfach alles
dran. Das fantastisch
gute, leider, Social Engineering,
fantastisch gutes Engineering,
das war, es war wirklich richtig
abgerundet, ein fantastisch guter
Versuch,
fantastisch krassen Exploit da reinzuschleusen.
Ja, also entweder war das wirklich ein State Actor,
der dann hinterher in der Lage sein
wollte, sich auf vierter Kiste dieser Welt
einzuloggen. Oder jemand, der
sich die Mühe gemacht hat, um das dann
teuer zu verkaufen.
Also das ist ein Exploit.
Ja, aber das ist ja quasi schon
unbezahlbar. Das ist ja
keine Geldzumme mehr wert.
Ja, ich meine,
das zu implementieren ist
nicht wenigen Leuten
möglich, wenn du auf die Idee kommst,
das zu tun. Und wenn du das einmal
geschafft hast, kannst du dir sagen, jetzt verkaufe ich das
als Exploit irgendwo.
Das ist für immer abgesichert.
Das muss kein...
Das ist ein Milliardenwert. Oder das hat nur irgendjemand
gemacht, um einen schönen Kongress-Talk zu halten.
Das wäre hart beeindruckend.
Sehr krass.
Übrigens... Literally
insane. Witzig wäre es, wenn
dann jemand hingeht und sagt, übrigens war ich,
ich kann es beweisen, ich habe nämlich den
Private Key.
Zu deinem Computer.
Nee, nee, es war ja wirklich...
Das war ja wirklich auch noch
safe. Es war, die Leute,
die das demonstrieren wollten, wie es
funktioniert, mussten das patchen,
weil in den
eingeschleusten Daten war der
Public Key von irgendjemandem
drin, der das Konnte
nur jemanden exploiten, der sich ausweisen konnte.
Das ist eigentlich das Coolste daran, dass du
beweisen kannst, dass du das warst,
wenn du das warst. Das ist bei anderen
Da klaimt das halt
meistens niemand, aber
das klingt wie bei einem Terroranschlag. Wir mittlerweile
jetzt Terroristen beweisen
müssen durch Videos, weil sich niemand mehr
glaubt in dieser aktuellen
Welt. Aber das ist genau so.
Das ist jetzt wieder ein Hot-Tag.
Wenn es nicht ein Nation-State-Actor war,
was ich für wahrscheinlich halt
immer noch am wahrscheinlichsten halte, oder jemand,
der sich gedacht hat, ich kann halt richtig viel Geld machen,
wäre die dritte, möglichst wahrscheinlich
geilste Variante, ist, dass dieses
Jahr beim Kongress sich jemand hinstellt.
Und es gibt ja manchmal so Talks, wo die Leute
wo du dir denkst,
what the fuck, wie kannst du damit
öffentlich gehen, dass du das gemacht hast?
Aber es sind halt häufig so stories,
wo die Leute sich dann auch monatelang
vorher, also gerade so was
das Zentrum für politische Schönheit
macht, wo die sich einfach auch
absichern mit
ihren Lawyers, dass sie das auch
claimen können, ohne dass sie wirklich
sofort eingesperrt werden.
Und dass sich jemand hinschaltet und sagt, ich hab das mal
gemacht, um euch mal wachzurütteln, was
alles schief gehen kann.
Hendricks Verschwörungstheorie des Tages ist
der Engineering Service Hahn steckt
dahinter.
Hahn Consulting. Oder Jan Böhmermann.
Habt ihr mal
diesen chinesischen Username
übersetzt? Vielleicht heißt das Hahn. Ist es überhaupt
chinesisch? Einfach GR10?
Ja, es klingt
als jartisch für mich, aber ja, es kann sein.
Oh no, es gibt eine Person namens GR10 mit der
Domain GR10.org. Associate Professor
of Cultural Studies in the Department of Cultural
and Religious Studies at the Chinese University of Hong Kong.
Hat bestimmt jetzt richtig viele Mails
bekommen. Richtig viele Mails.
Steht hier nicht irgendwo direkt
im Text von wegen I am not the person
behind X. Aber das ist bloß
das ist irgendein komplett anderer
Name, der zufällig in
lateinischen Lettern auf dasselbe
Spelling mappt und eigentlich auch komplett anders
ausgesprochen wird. Die Person hat sich selber
gr10.org als Domain genommen.
.org für eine persönliche
Website ist auch ein bisschen
Statement. Ich bin eine Organisation.
Er hat Markus
Becketal auch gemacht.
Der ist ja aber auch
eine Institution. Als er das gemacht hat,
war er vielleicht, also ich will ihm nicht zu nahe
treten, ich kannte ihn damals noch nicht, weiß nicht,
was er damals so als gemacht hat, aber
war jetzt nur so die
.org-Domain, die irgendwann dafür gesorgt hat, dass ich
auch mal irgendwann eine.org-Domain haben wollte.
Markus Becketal und Jan Böhmermann
sind G.I.T.L.E.D. haben wir das auch geklärt.
Und Satoshi.
Und Satoshi sowieso.
Das wäre mal ein Reveal.
Es wäre witzig, wenn der Private Key
für diesen
gleichzeitig irgendwie
der Key für das
Original-Bitcoin-Wallet ist.
Das wäre
so unglaublich impressive.
Das wäre so...
Okay, gut.
Thema abgehakt, würde ich sagen.
Ich glaube, die Folge geht mittlerweile auch schon eine Weile.
Ich würde am liebsten gerne zu den Picks
weitergehen.
alles klar, ja, ich muss sagen
das war eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr
spannende Folge und
ist noch nicht vorbei, nicht zum Abschluss
übergehen, sondern zu den Pics
und damit können wir uns
jetzt auch mit den Pics belohnen
dann sag doch mal an
was Pics denn du dieses Mal
und sag mir bitte, das ist nicht auf
GitHub gehostet
mein erstes Projekt ist nicht nur auf
GitHub gehostet, es interagiert
auch fast ausschließlich mit GitHub
Und zwar habe ich mir
ein Projekt rausgesucht, GitRose
ist eine witzige kleine
JavaScript-Library, die ich
privat nutzen wollte, um
Persistency für ein
Privatprojekt zu klären. Und zwar ist das immer
eines meiner Hauptprobleme, die ich habe, gerade wenn man Daten
auf GitHub-Pages schmeißt, ist, dass
das statische
Webseiten sind. Und statische
Webseiten haben diverse Probleme,
wo sie, also du kannst
auf gewisser Weise auch
Authentication machen, aber du bist halt
sehr eingeschnitten in den Möglichkeiten,
die du hast. Und unsere Webseite
läuft ja seit einer Weile jetzt auch auf GitHub-Pages,
also einfach eine React-App, die dynamisch den Feed lädt,
was ich auch nochmal optimieren möchte, weil
mir das nicht so gefällt, dass das dynamisch erst
lädt, das kannst du auch alles generieren,
aber dahingestellt.
Aber wir hatten auch schon mal vor
langer Zeit einen Pick gehabt, wo jemand
komplett SQLite zu Wasm gebaut
hat, dass du das embedden kannst in deiner
Frontend-Application mit und dann SQLite da einfach
im Browser ausführst, was auch abgefahren ist.
aber Gitforce ist noch ein bisschen
ein anderer Gedanke und zwar legst du da
deine Persistency Layer einfach in ein Repo
auf GitHub oder GitLab
aber unterstützt werden nur diese beiden Plattformen
weil es eben nicht Git spricht
sondern die HTTP
APIs von den beiden Plattformen anspricht
je nachdem was du machst
also ich
schrafe hier ein bisschen drum herum ohne zu sagen was es eigentlich ist
und die Idee davon ist, dass du eigentlich
eine CSV oder JSON Datei
in öffentlich oder ein privates Repo
legst und du kannst diese Daten lesen
kannst du die Query und du kannst aber auch da rein
schreiben. Schreiben machst du
indem du ein Git-Commit drauf machst. Eben nicht, sondern
über die HTTP-APIs
gehst, weil sonst müsstest
du komplett Git sprechen
im potenziellen Browser-Kontext und das
wäre technisch möglich, aber sehr viel
aufwendiger.
Das heißt,
GitHub hat
eine Möglichkeit über HTTPS zu
pushen. GitHub hat eine SAP, genau.
Es ist das.
Es ist kein Git-Push, aber
funktionell kommt am Ende
ein Commit. Du musst was sprechen, was die Gegenseite als
Git-Push versteht. GitHub will von dir auch
dann typische Git-Credentials im Sinne
von ein Username und eine E-Mail, die sie mit den
Commit dann verknüpfen können und das als Commit mit reinschreiben.
Also ja, essentiell kommt am Ende ein Commit bei raus,
aber du machst keinen Commit, sondern du sprichst
einen Put-Liquel-Story.
Du interagierst
nicht so, wie Git mit GitHub
interagieren würde, sondern du sprichst mit der
GitHub-spezifischen GitHub-Rest-API.
Selber auf der GitLab-Seite, deswegen
kann es nur die beiden Sachen, zumindest
fürs Schreiben. Lesen könnte
theoretisch natürlich auch freier sein, weil
da lesen sie einfach nur über RAW-Daten
die Datei aus, laden die Datei
komplett und machen das Querying lokal.
Heißt natürlich
nicht automatisch, dass du das komplett in eine
statische Webseite einbauen könntest und da auch
schreiben könntest, weil da müssen ja eine Credence natürlich auch damit
reingebacken werden, aber ich finde die Idee ist trotzdem
sehr, sehr cool, dass ich sehr viel,
also mir macht es sehr viel Spaß, immer Projekte so
aufzustehen, dass ich kein Hosting dafür betreiben
muss in keinster Weise und
wenn ich komplett meine Datenbank
in Anführungsstrichen, die keine Datenbank ist,
sondern CSV-Datei, einfach in den GitHub-Repo
schmeiße und damit interagiere, dann
macht mich das sehr, sehr glücklich, weil dann muss ich nichts
von diesem Stack betreiben, sondern dann läuft das einfach
vor sich hin. Und das fand ich eine sehr witzige Idee.
Ich bin darüber gestolpert, weil das
ein Bewerber bei uns auf Arbeit
uns gezeigt hatte,
als Demo, was er cool ist, gebaut hatte
und er hat darauf mit Gitvors was gebastelt
und das fand ich einen super coolen Gedanken
und hab ein bisschen rumgespielt.
bin in ein Issue reingerannt,
was mich ein paar Stunden gekostet hat
und hab da auch einen Publikum aufgemacht
mit einem winzig kleinen
Single-Character-Change,
der mich ein paar Stunden gekostet hat,
rauszufinden, was da überhaupt schiefläuft.
Aber seitdem weiß ich,
wie es funktioniert und es ist,
also der Change war ein bisschen lustig,
weil es literally einfach nur ein Kolon
zu dem Hash Octothalk macht,
aber ja,
ist ein lustiges Projekt, ich finde die Idee sehr toll.
Und deswegen ist es ein Pick.
Eine Datenbank auf GitHub-Lab-Basis.
So könnte man es beschreiben.
Das violatet quasi jede Definition von Datenbank.
Aber ja.
Ein Storage-Backend auf...
So könnte man es beschreiben.
Wie sehen die APIs aus, die ich da zum Schreiben nutzen kann?
Du machst ein Get-Request auf einen File-Identifier
und dann kriegst du einen JSON-Response,
wo die Datei-Contents Base64-codiert mit drin liegen
und Metadaten zum Beispiel...
Ah, S3 auf Git-Basis.
Also ja, die DHCP-Api sind natürlich sehr spezifisch für diese Services.
Und es wäre cool, wenn dieses Ding wirklich einfach direkt Git sprechen würde.
Und gerade, wenn wir vorhin schon bei dem Thema waren,
da war es eigentlich ganz gut dazu und einfach nativ Git spricht
und dann völlig egal ist, wo das hingeht.
Vielleicht wäre es mal ein cooles Spaßprojekt,
wenn man anfangen könnte, als nebenbei zu machen.
Ich finde die Idee einfach toll.
Ich habe einen ganz kurzen Pick.
Und zwar gibt es so viele Beschwerden darüber, dass der Rust-Compiler so schnell kompiliert und man überhaupt keine Zeit hat, sich zwischendurch einen Kaffee zu holen oder, wie man das gewohnt ist, von anderen Projekten zwischendurch mit den Kollegen irgendwie auf Bürostuhlen reitend im Flur zu fechten.
Deswegen gibt es ein erstaunlich
schickes Crate,
das heißt Coffee Break.
Wenn ich das in meine Dependency
in mein Projekt einziehe,
dann
ich lese es mal kurz die Beschreibung.
Coffee Break.
Coffee Break is a blazing fast
Rust Library
by Rust Developers for Rust Developers.
It is developer-friendly,
lets you take a break while compiling
your code. Eco-friendly,
The compiler is just taking a nap.
We do not compute the
Ackerman functions just dislike off.
Language server
unfriendly. Rust Analyzer is
also taking a nap.
Die Library sorgt einfach
dafür, dass wenn du das baust,
der Compiler eine beliebige
Zeit lang einschläft.
Also du musst aber explizit zum Coffee Break Statement in den Korbel packen.
Du musst einfach explizit
so ein Makro Coffee Break
aus so verzeichen mit einer gewünschten Zeit
hier in diesem Beispiel 5 Minuten
in deinen Code einbacken und dann
dauert dein Bild 5 Minuten.
Aber es ist kein busy waiting.
Ich finde es schön, dass hier steht, this create
requires correct grammar.
5 minutes ist okay, aber 5 minutes
nicht.
Bisschen korrekt, das muss schon sein.
Impressive.
Cool.
Schön, dass es solche Projekte gibt.
Spaßprojekte sind immer fantastisch.
Ja, da kann ich ja gleich mit meinem
Spaßprojekt ankommen.
Ihr habt ja hier auch schon immer gerne
über Programmiersprachen geredet und
da ist mir dann irgendwie auch,
ich scrolle selten Hacker News, aber
da habe ich das mal gemacht und da kam mir
HTML, the programming language
in meinen Weg.
HTML-lang.org
HTML
Ich dachte, das war eine
Specification für HTML.
Nein, nein, nein. The programming language is a
practical, Turing-complete,
stack-based programming language
based on HTML, the markup language.
It uses elements defined in
the markup language in order to do
computation.
Oh no.
Also, ja, es gibt
wie gesagt, data
value gleich 1 slash data.
Guck mal, so kann man auch seine Daten
irgendwo persistieren.
Da gibt es sogar schon fertige Highlight dafür.
Und ich dachte mir auf jeden Fall,
dass das euch gefällt. Ich habe es mir jetzt wirklich
nicht im Detail weiter angeguckt.
Und
ja, ich wollte euch das einfach nochmal zeigen.
Ihr könnt damit bestimmt viel mehr anfangen als ich.
Ach du Scheiße, ist das hässlich.
Installation to install HTML,
the programming language, download
and include the html.js
file via this script tag.
You may now begin programming in HTML.
Also, ich
muss auf jeden Fall irgendwas
minimales, auch wenn es nur ein Hello World ist, damit was
kündigt, damit ich mich dann an für immer
als HTML programmer. Ja, genau.
Man kann, auch wenn irgendwelche Noobs ankommen
und sagen, hier, kannst du mal was mit HTML
programmieren? Ja, klar, kann ich machen. Das nächste Mal, wenn
Tech-Bro da herkommt, ja, aber nein,
nein, nein, nein, ich bin wirklich
...
Wir machen das jetzt einfach noch schnell, wir betten das auf der
Akronomisierbar-Webseite ein, da kommt am Anfang,
das ist ja meistens eine React-Anwendung, da steht ja
meistens nichts außer DivID Main
und unten drunter kann auch ein bisschen sinnlos
HTML kommen, was dann
irgendwie den Konami-Code implementiert.
Oh Gott.
Ich verspreche nicht, dass es zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ihr diese Folge
gehört bereits auf akronomisier.bar
zu finden.
Oh Gott, ist das schlimm. Aber
fantastisch. Ich liebe es. Auf jeden Fall.
Ich dachte mir wirklich, dass du machst
und der ist der Mark
WebDev.
Das ist geil.
Das macht Vincent bestimmt auch sehr glücklich.
Hallo Vincent.
Aber ich habe auch noch was, was ein bisschen ernster
gemeint ist. Und zwar ist es tatsächlich
auch wieder auf GitHub. Und das ist
github.com slash mother of all
selfhosting. Und das ist
Eine Org, die verschiedene Ansible Playbooks liefert,
mit denen man...
Die Abwürdigkeiten smash.
Richtig.
Die alle möglichen Open-Source-Software-Projekte
offensichtlich mit einem Schnipp
auf deiner Hardware zur Installation bringt
und du ohne viel Detailwissen
erst mal an irgendwas rankommst,
womit du ein bisschen rumspielen kannst,
was das dezentrale Internet
wieder ein kleines Stückchen weiterbringt, würde ich sagen.
Und deswegen habe ich das auch nur
als Pick reingetan hier. Also, ne,
ich will jetzt nicht sagen, alle müssen ab sofort
jetzt hier irgendwie ihren Kram nur noch selbst
hosten, das hast du ja vorhin selber gesagt. So, manchmal will man das nicht,
manchmal kann man das auch nicht. Aber
wer es kann und wer
es möchte, hat auf jeden Fall hier
eine große Auswahl an Software,
die man mal ausprobieren kann.
Das ist ein ernstes Playbook, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Genau, ja. So, wir haben...
Was haben wir denn jetzt hier?
Das sind irgendwie...
Ich finde es schön, dass die einzelnen Unterordner
Just-Files beinhalten.
Ja, das ist irgendwie so
Make in neu, wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe. Ich benutze es auch auf Arbeit.
Ich muss den Leuten immer erstmal erklären, dass
sie doch Just verwenden sollen.
Und es sieht halt auf den ersten Blick aus wie
Make. Ach, aber wir haben ja
Konfix bestimmt, oder? Nee.
Es ist quasi einfach bloß Make in
schöner... Ach so, es ist einfach wirklich
eine eigene Sprache.
Jaja, Just-File. Aber es sieht aus wie Make.
Bis dir dann auffällt, oh, bei Make
ja Tabs verwenden.
Und hier nicht. Anyway,
ich habe null Ahnung von Ansible
und ich wüsste gar nicht, wo ich bei diesem Projekt als erstes
reingucken kann, weil jeder Ordner hat irgendwie so
ein
Tasks und Meta und
Defaults und sehe ich das richtig?
Du musst auf in die Smash Playbook Repo gehen
slash Docs slash Supported Services.
Das ist eine Datei,
wo sie eine schöne Tabelle haben von allem,
was du hier
sehr einfach damit aufziehen kannst.
Ob das jetzt dein
deine eigene Docker-Registry ist,
dein GitT, dein
Keycloak, dein Jitsi-Server, dein Matrix-Safe,
Postgres. Es gibt keinen Minecraft-Server.
Tja,
auch von Geo.
Und Uptime-Kuma,
ich mag Uptime-Kuma, sehr cool.
Spannend, das
ist cool, ich
nutze privat überhaupt kein Ansible,
aber ich finde es geil,
solche Dokus sind einfach geil.
Es ist schön,
wenn man sich immer auf einen Stack fürs Deployment
kann und
dann auch damit klarkommt und dann
Dinge sich einfach so
funktionieren. Ja, genau. Also ich meine,
ich bin da glaube ich auch über den Umweg
von Matrix-Docker-Ansible-Deploy,
was hier als Related-Playbooks
ganz unten auf der Seite, wie gesagt,
verlinkt ist. Das nutze
ich nämlich für mehrere
Matrix-Server, die ich betreibe
und ich habe vorher auch
von Ansible gehört, habe
irgendwann mal beschlossen, habe ich jetzt nicht
so den Use-Case dafür und das erstmal liegen lassen,
und dann kam aber halt mein Wunsch
nach einem eigenen Matrix-Verwehr hoch und dann
habe ich aus der Matrix-Bubble irgendwann
erfahren, dass es eben dieses Matrix-Docker-Ansible-Deploy-Playbook gibt,
was offensichtlich auf Ansible basiert.
Man installiert
Ansible auf dem Client-Gerät
und pullt sich das
Repo runter
und dann kann man mit
einer Vielzahl an Ansible-Kommandos,
die ich mir auch nie gemerkt habe
und deswegen schöne kleine Bash-Skripte
geschrieben habt, die mir da irgendwie das Ganze
irgendwie kürzer machen.
Ich muss mich endlich mal mit Ansible ausmachen.
Und dann macht dieses Ansible
SSH auf deine Kiste und führt dort die Befehle
aus, wie zum Beispiel
Docker-Container
irgendwie neu starten oder
neues Image ziehen
oder den System-D
Service
jetzt irgendwie neu starten und so weiter und so fort.
Und also noch einiges
haufenweise mehr. Wie gesagt, ich habe mich
vorher noch nie mit Ansible beschäftigt und ich benutze
jetzt, ohne mich intensiv damit auszukennen.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall auch ein sehr großes Universum,
in das man da reinpieken kann.
Das ist wohl wahr.
Thank you for teaching me this.
Wo habt ihr hier Forgeo gefunden?
Zweite von unten. Das ist nicht sehr alphabetisch
sortiert.
Wo seid ihr überhaupt? Ich bin auf
diese GitHub-Walk gegangen.
Wie mal den Link, den ich da drunter gepostet habe.
Im Pad. Und den wir auch
in die Show Notes mitpacken. Das ist diese
Supported Services.
Da steht aus irgendeinem Grund Forgeo.
ganz, ganz unten.
Unter Wireguard. Möglicherweise, weil das
einfach immer an die Markdown-Datei unten angehangen
wird, wenn jemand anderes oder jemand was
macht. Der komplette Rest hier...
Nee, stimmt nicht. Alles ist praktisch.
Dann habe ich an der richtigen Stelle gesucht. Es gibt
Forgeo.
Aber es gibt immer noch kein Minecraft.
Ich werde schon jetzt dann all meine Dockerfiles
als Einzige mit Playbooks bezeichnen.
Einfach nur zum Troll.
Ich habe zum Abschluss noch eine kleine
Geschichte. Ich habe euch nämlich jeweils einen
Aufkleber mitgebracht. Und das
kam daher, dass ich ja über
Dezentralisierung mit euch
sprechen wollte. Und es ist,
ihr kennt ja hier
Run DMC, dieses Meme, was da so
auf T-Shirts und überall immer zu sehen ist.
Und hier steht DCNTRL.
Und ich dachte, geil,
dezentral, das klebe ich mir auch auf meinen Laptop
und bring den
anderen beiden das mit, weil es war ja
schon letztes Jahr im Sommer, kurz
vor der Folge, in der ich eingeladen
werden sollte.
die lustige Geschichte kommt jetzt
dass ich nämlich jetzt dieses Jahr
bei den Chemnitzer Linux Tagen erst gelernt habe
dass das ja
von der Dezentrale aus Leipzig ein Aufkleber ist
weil ich nämlich bei der Dezentrale
in Leipzig diese Aufkleber
stapelweise gefunden hatte und dachte
Moment mal, das kommt mir doch bekannt vor
und dann so, ach ja Dezentrale
ja na klar, hier
das könnt ihr jetzt auch aufkleben
auf eure Tops
auf jeden Fall
finde ich eine freie Ecke
auf die...
Kannst du auch nachher erst machen.
Danke dir.
Ja, cool. Ich glaube, das ist auch ein wunderbarer
Punkt, um diese Folge erfolgreich
abzurunden.
Vielen lieben Dank, dass du hier zu Gast warst.
Sehr gerne. Fand ich auch.
Das war mein erstes Mal.
An dieser Stelle
an unsere treuen Hörer,
da wir ein Podcast sind,
wo sich die Hörer und die Podcaster
größtenteils
persönlich kennt. Wenn ihr ein cooles Thema habt
und mal mit uns darüber schwafeln wollt,
könnt ihr auch gerne euch mal melden
und dann schwafeln wir über euer Thema
bei Akronymisierbar.
Aber diese Stelle würde ich jetzt beenden
und du kennst dich aus, wie diese Folge
endet, deswegen würde ich dir gerne den
vierte Wand
durchbrechenden Meta-Countdown
für die Zuserver überlassen.
Die nächste Folge
in eurem Podcatcher startet in
2 1